[Musik]
guten Abend
Schicksalswahl oder die Wahl des Jahres
die Superlative haben sich in den
vergangenen Tagen und Wochen eigentlich
nur so übertroffen die Doppelwahl in der
Türkei Parlaments und
Präsidentschaftswahlen an einem Tag mehr
als 64 Millionen Wahlberechtigte seit 17
Uhr sind die Wahllokale geschlossen wir
sehen jetzt Bilder von der
Nachrichtenagentur Reuters 17 Uhr
unserer Zeit versteht sich und in der
Türkei in den Wahllokalen wird fleißig
ausgezählt hier bei uns bei Phoenix
gibt's jetzt das ganze Bild zu diesem
Tag und wir wollen die Sendung beginnt
mit einem ersten Blick auf die
Ergebnisse die uns so weit vorliegen
wir sehen hier in diesem Bild
Ergebnisse von der Nachrichtenagentur
Anker die Nachrichtenagentur Anker steht
Erde Opposition in der Türkei nahe und
wir sehen darauf ein Kopf an Kopf Rennen
zwischen Recep type Erdogan dem
amtierenden Präsidenten und Kemal Kilic
der olo dem
wichtigsten und schärfsten Konkurrenten
von Recep type Erdogan und wir haben
noch ein zweites Bild für Sie
vorbereitet das ist das aktuelle
Ergebnis die aktuelle Auszählung der
staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu
da zeigt sich das Recep time Erdogan
etwas deutlicher knapp 10% Punkte vor
kemalige liegt wo dran das liegt warum
diese Zahlen gerade so reinkommen wie
sie reinkommen darüber wollen wir jetzt
zu Beginn dieser Sendung sprechen mit
unserem Gast den ich bei uns im Studio
begrüßen möchte Professor Burak herzlich
willkommen
schön dass Sie da sind ich freue mich
sehr Herr Schoko ich habe es gerade
schon ein bisschen erklärt wir haben
gerade
verschiedene Zahlen die einlaufen
parallel Nachrichtenagentur Anker
Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu die eine
sieht Erdogan deutlicher vorne die
andere sieht ein Kopf an Kopf Rennen
Katharina Willinger unsere
Korrespondentin hat eben gesprochen von
einem Kampf der Zahlen können Sie diesen
Kampf der Zahlen ein bisschen erklären
erläutern ja das ist tatsächlich immer
wieder in der Türkei zu beobachten bei
den Wahlen dass es hier eine große
Verwirrung gibt nämlich einerseits die
Angaben der
agency also der staatlichen Agentur und
die sozusagen Angaben der
Opposition jetzt diesmal durch die Anka
und hier sehen wir immer eine Diskrepanz
das haben wir auch in den letzten Jahren
gesehen das hat einfach damit zu tun
dass die Zahlen der staatlichen Agentur
sozusagen als erstes die AKP Hochburgen
äh zeigen und dadurch natürlich durch
die gleichgeschalteten Medien der
Eindruck entsteht Erdogan gewinnt die
Wahlen also wir sind ja jetzt bei ähm
offiziell ist darauf an kopfrennen bei
Prozent für Medium type Erdogan und
Kemal Cruiser bei 47%. das sind die
Angaben der unterschriebenen Protokolle
der Wahlvorstände dann haben wir
parallel parallel die Zahlen der
staatlichen Agentur die bereits schon
sozusagen Erdogans sozusagen sieht im
Prinzip deutlich macht und das ist im
Prinzip eine Wahlstrategie auch der
Regierung hier eine Stimmung des
Wahlsieges in der Bevölkerung
zu zeigen und dann am Ende so hat er da
Präsident immer gemacht dann sozusagen
seinen Wahl Sieg auszurufen und er hat
natürlich da er hat im Hintergrund
natürlich noch mal den hohen
Wahlausschuss Jessica der das dann
amtlich auch noch mal erklären kann und
da ist der Rechtsweg dann ausgeschlossen
wird heute Abend noch ein bisschen
Zahlen Kuddelmuddel auf jeden Fall
werden wir werden da ja Erhellung
reinbringen gemeinsam in der nächsten
Zeit solange wir hier auf Sendung sind
an dieser Stelle wollen wir uns aber
gemeinsam erst einmal angucken was in
der Türkei bisher heute passiert ist wie
dieser Wahltag gelaufen ist
vor der AKP Zentrale in Istanbul laufen
Sie sich warm zum großen Siegeszug hier
sind sie sich sicher der Chef wird
gewinnen und die Osmanen kommt zurück in
unser Land
und was wenn nicht wir werden Ihnen das
Land nicht überlassen was wird diese
Nacht bringen eine Frage die die
chp-vorsitzende von Istanbul seit dem
frühen Morgen umtreibt sie glaubt an
ihre Partei das Oppositionsbündnis und
aber fürchtet die Wut der Erdogan
Anhänger
diejenigen die nicht an die Demokratie
Glauben sind in der Lage alles zu tun um
den Stuhl auf dem sie sitzen zu
zerstören den Tag wird sie deshalb mit
einem Bodyguard verbringen zum ersten
Mal in ihrem Leben denn die
Sicherheitssituation für Abgeordnete der
Opposition sei sehr angespannt so zeigen
Bilder den Oppositionsführer Kemal
College auch heute mutmaßlich Entschluss
sicherer Weste abgeschirmt von
Bodyguards an der wahlurnee in Ankara
unterdessen inszeniert sich Erdogan mit
Personalausweis und Enkelkind als
vorzeigedemokrat im Wahllokal in
Istanbul bis 17 Uhr konnte gewählt
werden die Wahlbeteiligung sei so heißt
es bereits überdurchschnittlich hoch zum
wahlabschluss ruft Erdogan über Twitter
dazu auf jetzt ist es wie immer die Zeit
die Wahl und zu schützen schützen sie
weiterhin den Willen unseres Volkes bis
die Ergebnisse feststehen wenig später
twittert auch der Herausforderer
verlassen sie niemals die wahluhren egal
was passiert bis der letzte
unterschriebene Wahl und Bericht
zugestellt wurde
überraschend früh gibt es an diesem
Abend erste Hochrechnungen die sehen
Erdogan von belastbar sind diese Zahlen
jedoch nicht
Katharina Willinger ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet in Ankara Grüße in die
türkische Hauptstadt hallo Frau
Willinger
Grüße zurück hallo ich habe schon gehört
von ihnen einen Kampf der Zahlen der
sich da abzeichnet aktuell wie
entwickelt sich dieser Kampf der zahlen
also hinter mir ich glaube sie können es
vermutlich nicht hören weil das Mikro
auf meine Stimme gerichtet ist hören wir
immer wieder laute Jubelgesänge ich
stehe vor der crp-parteizentrale die CRP
sagt nämlich wir liegen vorn wir liegen
vor allen Dingen in den Großstädten
deutlich vorn wenn man sich jetzt die
andere Seite anguckt die
Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu ashants die
gilt als regierungsmaß eine staatliche
Nachricht Agentur die sagt wiederum
Erdogan liegt deutlich vorn deswegen
habe ich auch vorhin schon gesagt es ist
ein Krieg der zahlen was wir allerdings
schon sagen können mit ziemlicher
Gewissheit die Wahlbeteiligung die war
heute Abend sehr sehr hoch sie liegt
wohl bei über 90%, das ist historisch in
der Türkei und das zeigt natürlich auch
noch mal ganz deutlich welche Bedeutung
diese Wahlen haben
erste Berichte gelesen über mögliche
Wahl Manipulation das war ja auch im
Vorfeld der Wahl ein großes Thema was
haben Sie darüber gehört bisher an
diesem Tag
also wir haben natürlich auch vor allen
Dingen über Social Media verfolgt dass
es Videos gab vor allen Dingen aus
Provinzen im Südosten der Türkei wo man
beispielsweise sieht wie
Gemeindevorsteher mehrere Stimmzettel
nacheinander abstempeln und zwar den
Stempel auf Erdogan legen das haben wir
aber auch schon in der Vergangenheit bei
bei früheren Wahlen immer wieder
beobachtet solche Unregelmäßigkeiten wir
haben natürlich mit Wahlbeobachtern
gesprochen auch die sagen uns ist gab
kleinere Unstimmigkeiten auf die man
noch mal genau schauen muss sie wollen
sich dazu morgen erst äußern aber was
man auch immer wieder betonen muss die
Türkei ist intern sehr gut aufgestellt
was Wahlbeobachter angeht allein die
Oppositionspartei stellt mehr als eine
halbe Millionen Wahl beobachte es sind
tausende Rechtsanwälte an den Urnen und
es haben sich auch sehr sehr viele
Menschen aus der Zivilbevölkerung bereit
erklärt diesmal als Wahlbeobachter
freiwillig über Initiativen über NGOs
teilzunehmen also es ist ganz wichtig
den Menschen hier dass diese Wahl
möglichst ohne große Unstimmigkeiten
ablaufen können ein großes Dankeschön an
dieser Stelle nach Ankara Katharina
Willinger
und warum so intensiv über mögliche Wahl
Manipulationen gesprochen wurde und was
das Erdbeben damit zu tun hat sehen wir
jetzt
ein Stück Alltag dort wo das Beben
besonders hart getroffen hat die Stadt
muss ich neu sortieren
[Musik]
wir müssen von vorne anfangen
Burak winzet ist hier der Vorsitzende
der CHP der führenden Oppositionspartei
die Parteizentrale seit dem Beben ein
umfunktioniertes Teehaus eine Woche vor
der Wahl wächst die Anspannung unter den
das größte Problem sind die die tot sind
Ihre Daten stehen noch im Wahlregister
die Befürchtung die Stimmen der Toten
könnten missbraucht werden um wie viele
Stimmen es genau geht es unklar denn
offizielle Zahlen sprechen von mehr als
6000 Toten Burak bin seit rechnet aber
mit mindestens 40.000 allein hier
also tote die wählen wir wollen mehr
darüber erfahren Verabredung mit zwei
dorf-
tatsächlich stehen hier mehrere Personen
die beim Erdbeben gestorben sind die
Dorfvorsteher werden die Namen von der
Liste löschen lassen am Wahltag
aufpassen dass kein Toter wählt hier sei
das möglich
in meinem Wahlbezirk gibt es 330 Fehler
ich kenne jeden von ihnen aber in
adiaman zum Beispiel gibt es vierteln
mit 10.000 WLAN dort kann nicht jeder
jeden kennen
die könnten betrügen die könnten
schummeln
die damit ist die AKP die Partei
Erdogans gemeint wir fragen nach bei dem
Mutter dem Statthalter eines Bezirks in
adiamanten gehört der Mann ist zuständig
für mehr als 6000 Menschen
seit 15 Jahren bin ich Bezirksvorsteher
ich weiß wer tot ist und wer nicht sie
kennen wirklich alle Menschen hier
also alle nicht aber hier weiß man
einfach ob es diese Person gibt oder
nicht
darauf nicht verlassen
schon in der Vergangenheit kam es zu
schweren Wahlbetrug dieses Mal werden
wir das versuchen zu verhindern indem
wir alle Vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen
sie haben deshalb hunderttausende
freiwillige im ganzen Land angeheuert
Menschen aus der Region die aufpassen
dass kein Toter wählt eine große Bürde
die nur schwer zu bewerkstelligen sein
wird
[Musik]
und aus Köln zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
Claudia Roth kulturstaatsministerin von
den Grünen hallo nach Köln
guten Abend Frau Roth nicht zuletzt
seitdem Protesten vor 10 Jahren haben
sie ja ein sehr intensives Verhältnis
eine sehr intensive Verbindung zur
Türkei auch so ein Wahlabend wie der
heutige was macht er mit ihnen
das ist unfassbar aufregend weil ich
glaube es ist die aller aller wichtigste
Wahl in diesen Zeiten es ist so wichtig
ob es in der Türkei tatsächlich einen
Frühling geben kann einen politischen
Frühling geben kann wie herrlich ja
gesagt hat und diese Wahl die bedeutet
ja nicht nur für die Menschen in der
Türkei und für die Entwicklung der
Türkei unendlich viel sondern auch für
viele viele Menschen hier bei uns die
Wurzeln haben und die genauso gespannt
in die Türkei gucken wie ich jetzt Frau
rot es ist an dieser Stelle noch viel zu
früh was über den Ausgang dieser Wahl zu
sagen deswegen zwei Szenarien die ich
Ihnen kurz ausbreiten möchte was würde
auf der einen Seite ein Sieg von Erdogan
bedeuten für die Türkei was würde auf
der anderen Seite ein Sieg von die
Türkei bedeuten aus ihrer Sicht
also im Moment ist tatsächlich sogar
eher der Streit oder die Macht der der
Zahlen die jetzt
reingeplustert werden und da haben wir
ja die Erfahrung gemacht so war das auch
in Istanbul bei der Wahl zum
Bürgermeister da wurde sehr schnell
versucht mit Zahlen Stimmung zu machen
die sich dann hinterher aber gar nicht
als wahr herausgestellt haben ja es wenn
Erdogan weiter an der Macht bleibt dann
glaube ich dass es eine unfassbare
Enttäuschung für viele ist die hoffen
dass die Türkei einen anderen Weg
eingehen kann erdogan ist verantwortlich
für eine große große Wirtschaftskrise
erdogan ist verantwortlich für die
Entrechtung des Rechts in der Türkei
erdogan ist verantwortlich dafür dass
viele Journalisten JournalistInnen
Künstler Künstlerinnen
Politiker wie Selle hat in dem mir
Tasche Kultur mit Zähne wie Osman Kavala
spielt seit Jahren im Gefängnis sitzen
und ich glaube es wäre für viele viele
Menschen die eine große Erwartung an
diese Wahl haben eine
unfassbar große Enttäuschung und auch
für uns glaube ich wäre es natürlich
würde ich mir sehr sehr wünschen dass
die Türkei die Chance hat auf einen
Wechsel auf einen Wandel auf einen
politischen Wandel wieder hin zurück zur
Rechtsstaatlichkeit dass die europäische
Türkei und viele viele Menschen gerade
auch junge Menschen sagen sie sind
Europäer wie Sie und ich sie wollen
diesen Weg nach Europa begehen dass
dieser Weg nach Europa sich wieder
öffnet der mit Erdogan und mit seiner
Politik praktisch verschlossen war und
wenn es denn so wäre dass die
Opposition die ja ein ganz breites
ungewöhnlich breites Bündnis darstellt
von jap bis zu bis zu sehr schön soll wo
die kurdisch dominierte HDP ja mit dabei
ist bis zu einem Partei bis zu einer
Partei von von Herrn Babacan einem
ehemaligen Anhänger von Erdogan vom
ehemaligen Außenminister also sein ganz
breites Bündnis dass dieses breite
Bündnis tatsächlich zeigen kann wie ein
neuer Weg für die Türkei aussieht ich
würde mir das sehr sehr wünschen sie
sprechen von einem neuen Weg für die
Türkei vielleicht ja auch dann von einem
neuen Weg für die deutsch-türkischen
Beziehungen sie haben es angesprochen es
gibt viele Menschen auch in Deutschland
mit Wurzeln in der Türkei auch
Wahlberechtigte jetzt bei diesen Wahlen
und das Verhältnis in den vergangenen
Jahren ich glaube es ist von meiner
Seite vorsichtig formuliert wenn ich
sage war unterkühlt stark abgekühlt da
würden sich manche Menschen glaube ich
auch was anderes wünschen
ja und ich glaube also sagen wir mal
geht es davon aus dass die Opposition
gewinnt dann ist es aber auch an uns zu
zeigen wir helfen bei diesem Wechsel bei
diesen Wandel mit denn faktisch ist
dieser Staat bankrott er ist bankrott
das hat
Erdogan ja zu verantworten es gibt eine
dramatische Inflation die Menschen auch
weit in den Mittelstand in der Türkei
sind verarmt sind wirklich verarmt und
wir müssen dann in eigenen Interesse
dass wir den demokratischen neu beginnen
unterstützen und einen wirtschaftlichen
Neubeginn unterstützen dann aber auch
diese neue Türkei oder diesen diese neue
Regierung mit unterstützen das müssen
wir wirklich tun dann muss es auch
aufhören diese eher anti-türkischen
Tendenzen die es ja auch in der
deutschen Politik gibt oder in deutschen
Parteien gibt die müssen dann wirklich
zu Ende sein sondern dann wird er sagen
wir helfen dieser Türkei wir helfen den
Menschen in der Türkei aus einer
dramatisch schwierigen Situation zum
einen tatsächlich die ganzen
Institutionen die sind ja
enddemokratisiert worden wenn ich das so
sagen darf der ganze Staatsapparat die
Medien die sind gleichgeschaltet also
ich meine wir können uns ja gar nicht
vorstellen einen Wahlkampf zu machen in
dem die gesamte Opposition überhaupt
keinen Zugang hat zu den öffentlichen
Medien zum Fernsehen die kommen da
praktisch gar nicht vor weil alles
gleichgeschaltet ist also von fairen
Verhältnissen zu sprechen fällt mir in
diesem Zusammenhang sehr schwer also wir
müssen diesen Wiederaufbau dann mit
großer Kraft und mit großer Überzeugung
unterstützen dass wir ein sehr großes
Interesse daran haben an einer sich
demokratisch verändernden Türkei in
einer sehr pro europäischen Türkei weil
das auch deutlich in unserem Interesse
ist wie das ausgeht Frau rot das haben
wir heute bei Phoenix in Blick
vielleicht gibt's ja sogar auch erst in
zwei Wochen bei einer Stichwahl dann das
endgültige Ergebnis dann reden wir gerne
noch einmal miteinander wenn sie möchten
nach Köln
ich danke Ihnen sehr und ich danke auch
den vielen vielen hundert den vielen
tausend Wahlbeobachter und
wahlbeobachterinnen die ihr Möglichstes
tun damit es nicht so Manipulationen an
den Urnen oder mit den Urnen kommt ich
danke Ihnen
wir sind zurück im Phoenix Studio und
ich bin wieder bei meinem Gast im Studio
Professor Buddha schön dass wir
weitersprechen können freut mich Frau
Roth hat gerade gesprochen von der
Wichtigkeit dieser Wahl in den
vergangenen Tagen war oft zu lesen auch
der Begriff Schicksalswahl inwieweit
trifft das aus ihrer Sicht naja es ist
schon eine Schicksalswahl nämlich die
Türkei entscheidet ja heute möchte sie
zurück in eine parlamentarische
Demokratie oder möchte sie den Weg einer
Autokratie unter Präsident unter
Präsident Erdogan weitergehen und das
ist schon eine große
Schicksalswahl in dem Sinne weil ein
zurück zur Demokratie bedeutet nämlich
dass die Menschen auf atmen können es
die Journalist nicht verfolgt werden die
Opposition nicht kriminalisiert wird
auch insbesondere die Pro kurdische HDP
die ja massiv vor den Wahlen
kriminalisiert wurde und auch viele von
deren Mitgliedern und Journalisten
wurden sozusagen festgenommen vor den
Wahlen das heißt ein zurück zu
parlamentarischen Demokratie würde eine
Normalisierung bedeuten würde aber auch
bedeuten dass man so jahrhundert fragen
wie die Kurden Frage lösen kann
gemeinsam mit der prokurischen HDP mit
dem 6er Bündnis vermutlich und hier auch
wichtige sag mal Baustellen zentrale
Baustellen der Türkei einfach aus dem
Weg räumt und
und die Möglichkeit für die Türkei ist
wieder ein Sprung nach vorne zu machen
ein ein zurück zu parlamentaren
Demokratie bedeutet mehr Pressefreiheit
Meinungsfreiheit und ähm bedeutet auch
dass es weniger Konflikt auch hier in
Deutschland gibt also das wird auch der
Integration hier in Deutschland
förderlich sein wenn die Türkei sich für
Präsident Erdogan entscheiden wird also
für ein weiter so dann wird es
konfliktreicher werden auch mit Blick
auf außenpolitische Beziehungen zu
unseren Nachbarländern
aber auch mit Blick auf die Innenpolitik
der Türkei das heißt das Land wird unter
Präsident Erdogan nicht zur Ruhe kommen
sie haben ja auch den Wahlkampf verfolgt
mit Sicherheit in den vergangenen Tagen
und Wochen das sei am Anfang so aus als
wäre der Wahlkampf für türkische
Verhältnisse relativ
friedlich jetzt hat er aber dann doch
noch mal ein Schärfe gewonnen in den
vergangenen Tagen es gab Wahlkampf
Auftritte auch von Kemal Kilic stardolo
wo er mit schussweste auch auftreten
musste weil es Befürchtungen eben gab es
könnte beispielsweise in Attentat auf
ihn verübt werden was sagt denn diese
Verschärfung dieser aggressive Ton auf
der Schluss geraden das Wahlkampfs noch
mal über die Bedeutung der Wahl
zusätzlich ja es gab tatsächlich große
Ausschreitungen auch Angriffe gegenüber
der Oppositionen beispielsweise wurde
der Oberbürgermeister von Istanbul vor
den Augen der türkischen Polizei mit
Steinen angegriffen so dass er sein
Wahlkampf abbrechen musste quasi und das
zeigt eigentlich welche Bedeutung diese
Wahl auch für Präsiden erdogan hat
nämlich es geht hier um alles so oder
nichts für präsent Erdogan wenn er diese
Wahl verliert hat er wirklich viel zu
verlieren nicht nur seine politische
Macht auch ganz viel Vermögen zum guten
Ton in Anführungszeichen im türkischen
Wahlkampf gehört ja immer so ein
bisschen den Gegner zu diskreditieren
lassen wir dieses sich gegenseitig
diskreditieren mal kurz aus dem vor was
waren denn die großen Themen die diesen
Wahlkampf geprägt haben ja die großen
Themen die liegen auf der Hand die
Wirtschaft also die Wirtschaft ist am
Ende das Land ist tatsächlich beim kurz
so wie es auch klar der rot gesagt hat
das Land hat eine große Katastrophe
hinter sich nämlich die
Erdbebenkatastrophe mit wo über 50.000
Menschen gestorben sind und das Land ist
eigentlich steht vor einem
Scherbenhaufen und dieses ein
Scherbenhaufen muss natürlich die
Opposition falls sie die Wahl gewinnt
wieder versuchen zu bereinigen und das
Land nach vorne zu bringen und das wird
eine große Mammutaufgabe für die
Opposition wir haben gerade kurz schon
das Erdbeben die Erdbeben Katastrophe
angesprochen
für den Umgang für das Management für
die Hilfe die sehr schleppend anlief
auch mit Blick auf diese erdbebenkrise
ist die Regierung in Ankara ist
Präsident Erdogan ja auch massiv
kritisiert worden aus ihrer Sicht ihrer
Einschätzung nach wie viele
Wählerstimmen hat ihnen das denn
gekostet wie viele Anhänger sind denn
deshalb von ihm abgewichen ja das ist
tatsächlich ganz interessant dass die
Erdbebenkatastrophe im Prinzip keine
Auswirkungen auf die Umfragewert von
Präsident erdogan hatte ja es sind 50
000 Menschen gestorben es ist auch
keiner in der Regierung zurückgetreten
obwohl es auch hier politische
Verantwortung gab aber das hat sich
nicht gezeigt in den Umfragewerten und
das zeigt sich jetzt auch nicht an
diesen Kopf an Kopf Rennen Präsident
erdogan hat wenn man den offiziellen
Angaben der unterschriebenen Protokolle
der Wahlvorstände Glauben schenkt ist
das ein Koffer Kopf rennt wo ähm
kämmerkristall im Prinzip nur mit einem
Prozent vorne ist und
immerhin noch 46% hat trotzdem
Wirtschaftskrise und trotz
Erdbebenkatastrophe die offiziellen
Zahlen hat schokor waren ein sehr sehr
gutes Stichwort wir wollen jetzt an
dieser Stelle und sie nämlich einen
Blick gönnen ins türkische Fernsehen in
die Berichterstattung des staatlichen
türkischen Fernsehsenders TRT wir haben
es eben gesagt die Zahlen die
entsprechend veröffentlicht werden und
diese gleich sehen
immer die Frage
sehr den getraut werden darf aber das
werden wir dann gleich im Studio auch
noch mal einordnen für sie
sind
in der Türkei bei den
Präsidentschaftswahlen nach dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen möchten wir auch
mal auf die
Abgeordneten Wahlen sehen und wir können
sehen dass dort
wir die Karte von der Türkei sehen
können und bei der Grafik können wir
sehen dass
62,37 3% der Wahlurnen ausgezählt wurden
HP hat
23,42 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen die
e-party sehen wir sie haben fast zehn
Prozent der Stimmen bekommen die MHP hat
52 Abgeordnete und 11,31 Prozent der
Stimmen bekommen die Grünen Linkspartei
also die Nachfolgepartei der HDP hat
8,22 und 58 Abgeordnete
erlangen können und die neue referpartei
hat fünf Abgeordnete bisher
bekommen können durch die Wahlen und die
übrigen Parteien einen Abgeordneten sie
haben 6,44 äh Stimmen Prozent der
Stimmen bekommen und wir sehen uns
natürlich auch die Bündnisse an es gibt
fünf Bündnisse in der Türkei dieses
System
bei bei diesem Wahlen spielen auch die
Dynamik in der der Bündnisse eine große
Rolle wir sehen dass die MHP 52
Abgeordnete entsenden können die BWP und
die neue der farbpartei gemeinsam mit
der
republikbündnis haben insgesamt
52,27 Prozent der Stimmen und die Volks
das volksbündnis dem Gegenwart
33,32%. der Stimmen bekommen ATA etfaki
ist das Bündnis von Sinan Ohren sie
haben
1,68% der Stimmen für die für das für
das für die bei den Parlamentswahlen
erlangt das werden wir auch später mit
unseren Gästen noch analysieren die Map
und Bündnis haben
9%, der Stimmen insgesamt bekommen die
Grünen Linkspartei 58
Abgeordnete mit 8,22% die Stimmen und
die sozialistische das sozialistische
Bündnis hat
0,21 und dann haben wir auch noch
Parteien die angetreten sind außerhalb
vom Bündnissen als einzelparteien auch
die memde CAT Partei beispielsweise
hatte 0,82 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen
ja wenn wir nun auf unsere allgemeine
Grafiken haben wir jetzt gerade gesehen
wenn wir nun zu den Provinzen gehen ich
möchte gerne mit Ankara beginnen 75% der
Wahlurnen wurden ausgezählt und drei
Viertel der Stimmen wurden also
ausgezählt und ihn ankara hat sich der
Erde
47,63% die Stimmen bekommen
45,5%
6,47 % und obwohl er zurückgetreten ist
von den Wahlen
0,40% der Stimmen hat er bekommen
[Musik]
ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass 75%
der
Wahlurnen ausgezählt wurden wir gehen
nun weiter zu dem Provinzen und für uns
sind die Städte natürlich sehr wichtig
die mega Stadt Istanbul ist sehr wichtig
und dort wurden
66,17% der Wahlurnen geöffnet und hier
können wir auch die Stimmen sehen können
48,25% der Stimmen Ohren mit 4,5 2 und
36,85 wir können sehen das sofort
Erdogan liegt hier in Istanbul 11
Millionen
rund 11 Millionen Wähler und Wähler
haben gewählt und
die
Wahlbeteiligung auch in den anderen
Provinzen liegt bei etwa 90% bei dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen in Istanbul
eine andere Stadt ist mir da schauen wir
jetzt hin
die geöffneten Wahlurnen sind es
ungefähr
74,44 Prozent
da hat welche type Erdogan 32 Prozent
ungefähr bekommen
62% bekommen
sie dann Ohren hat sich
4,85% bekommen und die Wahlbeteiligung
lag bei
90,06% auch mal dem Insel hat das ein
Rückzug dennoch 12000
12.900 Stimmen bekommen und liegt unter
einem Prozent
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Zuschauer wir haben die
Daten jetzt geteilt
das Bild erzählt uns natürlich was bei
den Parlamentswahlen sind wir jetzt auch
bei 65% der gezählten
Stimmen
Professor burhanistin Duran bei uns was
erzählt das Bild wie lesen Sie das Bild
was wir da haben
wir
die Türkei ist von einer demokratischen
Wahl von einer demokratischen Prüfung
mit einem
ja wir sind mit Bravour bestehen
dass die Wahlen in Frieden und in Ruhe
abgelaufen sind und ein Kopf an Kopf
Rennen an den Wahlurnen finde ich sehr
wichtig für unsere Demokratie
können
sein dass die
zweite Runde der Wahl
in Frage kommt wenn diese
Ergebnisse weiterhin so bleiben dann
wird es eine zweite Runde geben
Vater er mag gibt eine Erklärung ab
eigentlich wurden die Stimmen abgegeben
wir hatten keine Probleme hinsichtlich
der Sicherheit der Wahlen
wir haben gesehen trotz einiger
kleinerer Probleme dass das System
funktioniert die Wahlbeobachter waren an
dem Wahlurnen es gab auch einige
Widersprüche
gleichzeitig haben die
kreiswahlkommissionen auch Vertreter
dort an den wahlordnen Urnen und auch
die Parteien haben Beobachter entsandt
an die Wahlurnen und wir haben gesehen
dass das alles möglich ist um die
Sicherheit Wahlen der herzustellen zu
gewährleisten trotz der vorher erzeugten
Panik Atmosphäre können wir doch sagen
dass es nicht notwendig war so viel
peinlich zu verursachen wenn
sie nun vor allen anderen vor der
Auszählung der Stimmen meinen das
Ergebnis zu wissen dann müssen sie ja
wirklich
prophezeien können was da an Stimmen
herauskommt aber wichtig ist für uns was
ausgezählt worden und für uns ist
wichtig die
was für uns sind die unterschriebenen
Protokolle der Ergebnisse aus den
wahlordnen ausschlaggebend und so können
wir erst auch sagen wie das Wahlergebnis
ist es wird auch behauptet also es gibt
Widersprüche und die
scheint im Vorsprung zu sein weil die
Wahlurnen bei deren Auszählung wir
widersprochen haben hier in diese
Ergebnisse nicht einfließen wurde
behauptet und da möchte ich auch sagen
dass das nicht richtig ist aber wir
haben es ja nicht eilig jede Partei hat
die Möglichkeit bis Dienstag äh
Widerspruch zu einzulegen gegen die
Ergebnisse an bestimmten
Wahlurnen und bis 15 Uhr am kommenden
Dienstag hat jede Partei und jeder die
Möglichkeit Widerspruch einzulegen
deswegen gibt es gar keinen Grund zur
Panik und zu Eile sowie sowohl bei den
äh
Präsidentschaftswahlen als auch bei den
Abgeordneten Wahlen können wir sagen
dass unsere Partei und unsere
Präsident mit weitem Abstand vorne liegt
trocknet
ich möchte ganz klar folgendes sagen die
Ergebnisse die wir bisher haben bei den
Parlamentswahlen da können wir wirklich
ganz klar sagen dass die dass das
Republik Bündnis mit Abstand vorne ist
und wir hoffen sehr dass das auch dabei
bleibt und wenn die Wahlen wenn die
Stimmen weiter ausgezählt sind werden
wir diese Ergebnisse auch weiter
bestätigen können
er hat zur Ruhe aufgerufen und hat es
besonders das Bild im Parlament
unterstrichen und hat für die Partei für
die AKP eine
positives Bild gezeichnet
[Musik]
ein klares Bild für die für das Bündnis
der republikanische Republikaner was
denken Sie dazu
ich finde das sehr wertvoll dass
diese
Erklärung gemacht haben das ist eine
sehr wertvolle Erklärung eine wichtige
Erklärung
und besonders dass er die Wahlkommission
unterstrichen hat das wird natürlich
sehr wichtig sein
können
auch die anderen Parteien sollten keine
anderen Erklärungen abgeben letztendlich
werden werden die unterschriebenen
Protokolle die Wahl
entscheiden
und momentan zeigt sich das die das
republikanische Bündnis momentan vorne
liegt und auch
der Staatspräsident Erdogan auch vorne
liegt bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen ein
anderer wichtiger Punkt von Herrn
gesagt hat
waren die
wo er auf die
Unterschiede zwischen den Zahlen
hingewiesen hat und hat gesagt
dass sie sie Widersprüche einfach
dadurch entstanden sind dass sie
Einsprüche noch nicht ausgewertet waren
[Musik]
wir erwarten natürlich auch dass die
Opposition in einer demokratischen
Verantwortung
die Ergebnisse anerkennt das ist der
demokratische Weg
das ist das Ergebnis aus den Wahlurnen
und wo der
Staatspräsident Erdogan vorne liegt und
die das
bündnisrepublikanische Bündnis vorne
liegt dass ein demokratisches Ergebnis
und wir hoffen dass die Politiker in den
Erklärungen die sie demnächst abgeben
werden und
auch die kritische Lage einfach nicht
mehr anfeuern werden und in den nächsten
ein zwei Stunden
werden sollten sagen die Gegenseite hat
gewonnen egal welche Seite gewonnen hat
und dieses auch akzeptieren
ich bedanke mich bei
Duran der General gehört
allgemeinkoordinaten von der von dem
politischen Forschungsinstituts ich
möchte Sie bitte
noch mal so das Bild zu interpretieren
was sagen Sie alle unsere Gäste auch
Alice sein jawohl nur sagen dass
wir das Gesamtbild betrachten müssen dr
Murat Jürgens
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen ist ja
das endgültige Ergebnis noch nicht klar
wir müssen auf das Ergebnis warten also
wir wissen wer vorne steht wird der Typ
erdogan ist mit Abstand weiter vorne
allerdings bedeutet das noch nicht dass
er gesiegt hat die
Opposition hat einen stimmenblock von 48
% und
muss mehr als zwei Prozent auf diese 48%
der vorhandenen Stimmen noch drauflegen
aber leider bzw aber wir können sehen
dass du nicht einmal diese 48%
konsolidiert sind konsolidieren konnte
es sogar weiter zurück gefallen
hatte ja die Kandidatur von Herrn König
im Vorfeld kritisiert und wir sehen dass
sie damit Recht gehabt hatte also er
konnte nicht einmal diese 48 Prozent der
vorhergesagten Stimmen erreichen es gibt
natürlich auch unterschiedliche Faktoren
die bei den Wahlen eine Rolle gespielt
haben vielleicht haben sie vorher schon
darüber gesprochen
dass die dass das republikbündnis von
Erdogan wirklich mit großem Abstand
vorne liegt zeigt dass hier die
nationalen bzw die nationalistischen
wählerstand nicht akzeptiert haben nicht
anerkannt haben und ähm
auch im Osten und Südosten des Landes
die Problematik mit der Unterstützung
der
Terrororganisationen im Südosten des
Landes und die Haltung von dem
volksbündnis zu diesem Thema hat
sicherlich auch eine Rolle gespielt
ein wirklicher Wahlkrimi der sich da
abspielt einen Kampf um die Zahlen so
haben wir das schon mal genannt heute
und so wird das wahrscheinlich sich
heute den ganzen Abend auch noch
weiterentwickeln an dieser Stelle möchte
ich sprechen mit Jürgen hart der mir
jetzt zugeschaltet ist von der CDU
außenpolitischer Sprecher viele Grüße
nach Düsseldorf
guten Abend Herr hart wie verfolgen sie
das was da aus der Türkei gerade
rüberkommt und wie ist ihre Lesart
dieses Kampf um die Zahlen
ich fand sehr bemerkenswert was die
beiden
wichtigen thp-politiker der
Bürgermeister von Istanbul und der
Bürgermeister von Ankaras gesagt haben
das sind hier zwei die auch als
Präsidentschaftskandidat in Frage
gekommen wäre nur die sagen beide das
ist Teil der Propaganda von Erdogan
jetzt quasi sich zum Sieger auszurufen
er hat die Kontrolle über die
staatlichen Medien Medien auch über die
staatliche Nachrichtenagentur die ja
diese Zahlen präsentiert und deswegen
bin ich sehr vorsichtig mit einer
jetzigen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt eine
Bewertung des Ergebnisses ich glaube es
zeichnet sich ab der Abstand wird ja
auch kleiner das ist in jedem Fall eine
Stichwahl geben wird wohl in 14 Tagen um
das Präsidentenamt und wie das im
Parlament aussieht das wäre ja total
wichtig wenn ein anderer Präsident wenn
die Tape sich durchsetzt mit ihrem
Präsidentschaftskandidaten dass man dann
auch eine Mehrheit im Parlament hat die
Verfassung wieder an den Punkt
zurückzutreten an dem Erdogan sie
verändert hat nämlich weg von dieser
reinen Presse diealdemokratie wieder hin
zu einer Dualität zwischen einer
Regierung die den par unverantwortlich
ist und einem direkt gewählten
Präsidenten das ist ja das große Ziel
der Oppositionen und das geht natürlich
nur dann wenn auch die Mehrheit im
Parlament dafür da ist aber für beides
können wir heute zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
kurz nach neuen hier meine ich noch kein
seriöses Urteil abgeben diese Bewertung
Herr hart der aktuellen Zahlen die will
ich Ihnen auch gar nicht abverlangen und
die möchte ich gar nicht von ihnen haben
was mich aber interessiert ist was
wünschen sie persönlich denn für einen
Wahlausgang die Bundesregierung
beispielsweise ist ja sehr verhalten
gewesen auch in den Tönen im Vorfeld das
gebietet vielleicht der diplomatische
Anstand auch so Claudia rote eben die
wir geschaltet haben war dann schon
deutlich
deutlicher auch und hat klar
durchklingen lassen was sie sich wünscht
was wünschen sie sich was wünscht die
CDU sich wir haben in den letzten
Monaten die Diskussion erlebt mit der
Türkei bezüglich des nato-beitritts von
Finnland und Schweden Schweden ist nach
wie vor pending das ist also noch nicht
entschieden die türkische Regierung hat
hier noch kein grünes Licht gegeben das
würde ich mir dringend Wünschen für
den NATO-Gipfel Anfang Juli Mitte Juli
in in Litauen und darüber hinaus gibt es
natürlich die Frage der Unterstützung
der Ukraine die Frage der Stellung der
Türkei in diesem Konflikte in diesem
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine da
haben sich bei mir in der letzten Zeit
doch deutliche Fragezeichen gezeigt ob
Erdogan und diese Regierung wirklich
diejenige ist die die Türkei ganz dicht
an unserer Seite an der Seite der
westlichen Welt führt und das zweite ist
das natürlich beunruhigend sind die
Wirtschaftszahlen aus der Türkei ob das
jetzt allein die Verantwortung des
Präsidenten erdogan ist sei
dahingestellt aber die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung gelandet ist sehr schlecht
die Entwicklung des Türkischen Lira ist
sehr schlecht die Staatsschulden zum
Teil in ausländischer Währung
galoppieren also das Land bewegt sich
wird wirtschaftlich im Augenblick nicht
auf einem guten Weg und das ist ja auch
ein großes Interesse von uns wir wollen
ja einen starken Partner Türkei der eben
auch wirtschaftlich stark ist und nicht
zuletzt haben ja viele Menschen die hier
in Deutschland leben mit türkischen
Wurzeln eben auch Vermögen in der Türkei
sie haben dort Besitz in der Türkei
machen dort vielleicht Geschäfte
insofern kann ich mir vorstellen dass
ein Neuaufbruch in der Türkei für uns
alle von Vorteil wäre ob wir das Erleben
werden ein neuer Präsident und eine neue
parlamentsmeiert oder nicht wird man
erst in einigen Tagen sagen können wenn
wir diesen neuen Präsident erleben
würden dann wird vielleicht aber auch
ein anderes Thema aus deutscher Sicht
ganz spannend das haben sie gerade nicht
angesprochen das flüchtlingsabkommen mit
der EU auch kemalster Rollo hat
Wahlkampf damit gemacht syrische
Flüchtlinge in der Türkei wieder zurück
in ihre Heimat schicken zu wollen wie
sehr Bestand an dieses Abkommen mit der
EU haben wird das ist auch noch eine
andere Frage was denken sie denn darüber
ich glaube dass das eu-türkei-abkommen
ein ganz wichtiger europäischer Baustein
war um das Thema Flüchtlinge in den in
der Folge des Syrien Krieges aus
europäischer Sicht einigermaßen in Griff
zu bekommen ich glaube wir hätten noch
einige hunderttausend mehr Flüchtlinge
in Deutschland aufnehmen müssen wenn die
Türkei das nicht machen würde deswegen
ist dieses Abkommen sehr wichtig und
viele Menschen die an der Europäischen
Union und ihrer Kraft zweifeln und zu
helfen bei der Bewältigung dieser
flüchtlingsherausforderung sein daran
erinnert dass dieses Abkommen vielleicht
auch ein Muster sein könnte für andere
Staaten aus denen wir große
Flüchtlingszahlen erwarten müssen in der
Zukunft also insofern setze ich schon
drauf dass es nicht nur mit der Türkei
Bestand hat dieses Abkommen sondern dass
wir vielleicht auch als Europäische
Union die Kraft haben solche humanitär
verantwortbaren aber eben auch wirksamen
Abkommen zu schließen und insofern
glaube ich dass das auch mit der Türkei
weiter so bestehen kann allerdings wird
die Türkei von uns auch einen
entsprechen keine Gegenleistung erwarten
und ich glaube das sind ist die Frage
der Handelsbeziehungen zur Türkei also
inwieweit wir als Europäische Union
bereit sind weiter in den Handel
eu-türkei zu investieren das sind glaube
ich zwei Seiten ein und derselbe
Medaille und das will ich jetzt auch mal
gar nicht kritisieren weil so geht
Politik die Türkei braucht dringend
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung und den kann
es nicht gegen kann die Türkei nicht
gegen die EU sondern nur mit der EU
bekommen und insofern wird der
zukünftige Präsident egal aber jetzt
Erdogan heißt oder kennt ja logo heißt
wird entsprechend die Möglichkeiten
ausloten müssen was mit der EDU zu
machen ist und da wird vielleicht das
ein oder andere was im Wahlkampf gesagt
wurde
dann doch in den Hintergrund gehen und
der Pragmatismus in den Vordergrund
rücken die Türkei braucht die EU aber
wir als EU wollen auch eine gute starke
Türkei an unserer Seite
die Türkei braucht was die EU braucht
was der pragmatische Ansatz den sie
gerade skizziert haben aus meiner Sicht
komplett nachvollziehbar für manch
anderen vielleicht insofern nicht als
das der Europäischen Union oft
vorgeworfen wurde in den vergangenen
Jahren das in Fragen der
menschenrechtsfälle zum in der Türkei
dann vielleicht doch das ein oder andere
Mal zu oft ein Auge zugedrückt wurde
weil die Abhängigkeit von der Türkei so
groß ist wie sehen Sie das und was
glauben sie würde sich da vielleicht zum
besseren sage ich jetzt mal so ein
bisschen bewertend auch verändern können
wenn killic stadtolo an die Macht käme
also ich erhoffe mir schon von einem
Präsidenten killischer Holo dass er die
Verfolgung von politischen Gegnern und
das drohende Verbot von Parteien wir
haben hier in diesem Wahlkampf zum
Beispiel eine Partei die bei der letzten
Wahl über 10% der Stimmen bekommen hat
die kurdische Partei die sich nicht
zugetraut hat unter dem eigenen Namen
wieder anzutreten weil eine Verein
Verbote Partei im Raum bestand und sie
sind deswegen unter dem Mantel eines
grünen links Bündnisses ins Rennen
gegangen mit ihren Kandidaten so etwas
ist natürlich kein fairer Wahlkampf das
ist ein Verstoß gegen demokratischer
Grundprinzipien und ich setze schon
darauf dass das unter einer anderen
Präsidenten nicht so wäre genauso wie
ich glaube dass die Verfolgung von
Journalisten ein ganz kritischer Punkt
ist wir haben auch gerade hier in meine
Region im im Rhein rohrraum eine ganze
Reihe von von Journalisten die hier
teilweise gelebt haben oder noch leben
und die in der Türkei verfolgt sind auch
im Gefängnis sitzen bis zum heutigen
Tage das wird sich hoffentlich ändern
ob der Türkei tatsächlich sich von uns
in sehr Form belehren lässt in
Anführungsstrichen dass jetzt wir jeden
einzelnen menschenrechtsverstoßenden
Türkei zum Anlass nehmen sollten die
Beziehungen einzutrüben da glaube ich
setze ich eher drauf dass am Ende des
Tages eine engere Anbindung der
Europäischen Union an die Türkei eine
größere Offenheit auf beiden Seiten mehr
für die Menschenrechte in der Türkei
leisten kann als wenn wir da immer
entsprechend kritisch darauf hinweisen
das machen wir als politische Parteien
das machen wir als Bundestagsfraktion
die Bundesregierung muss mit der Türkei
leben so wie sie ist egal wie die Wahlen
heute nach der ausgehen Jürgen hart der
außenpolitische Sprecher der CDU vielen
Dank für das Gespräch
auf Wiedersehen
und zurück im Phönix Studio und zurück
bei Professor Burak chopour unserem Gast
im Studio Herr topur was ich gerade raus
gehört habe auch bei Herrn hart ist die
Hoffnung auf einen Machtwechsel auf
einen Zeitenwechsel eine Zeitenwende
auch in der Türkei diese Hoffnung im
Oppositionslager die war ja in diesem
Wahlkampf sehr groß auch die
Berichterstattung gegen immer wieder in
diese Richtung vielleicht ist die Chance
für die Opposition gerade so groß wie
sie noch nie gewesen ist tatsächlich
nicht zuletzt weil sich da auch ein so
großes Bündnis geeint hat und
zusammengetan hat und Hinterkammer
gestellt hat als Spitzenkandidaten über
Aldi Wochen Monate jetzt diese Euphorie
konnten sie die nachvollziehen oder
vielleicht dann doch nicht ganz so sehr
ja zum Teil schon aber zum Teil auch
nicht ich bin ja Politikwissenschaftler
und ich möchte muss das natürlich alles
objektiv und neutral und auch kritisch
sehen also man muss die Kirche auch im
Dorf lassen dass das
Sechser Bündnis angeht
die Wahl wenn sie denn geworden wird
heute oder in zwei Wochen für das
Oppositionsbündnis
am nächsten Tag wird die Welt für die
Türkei nicht in Ordnung sein und die
Türkei wird auch nicht am nächsten Tag
zur zuvor zeige Demokratie Norwegen auch
mit dem 6er Bündnis nicht dafür ist
diese 6er Bündnis einfach viel zu
heterogen es ist ein Sammelsurium von
Kemalisten ultra-nationalisten
Islamisten aber auch islamisch
konservativen also die Abspaltung der
AKP und ähm das zeigt natürlich wie vor
welchen Problemen auch dieses Sechser
Bündnis stehen wird also es hat keinen
gemeinsamen Nenner außer jetzt die
Abfall Erdogans und den äh das zurück
zur parlamentarischen Demokratie gibt es
keine Übereinstimmung in so wichtig
zentralen Zukunftsfragen der Türkei
nehmen Sie die Kurdenfrage nehmen Sie
die Frauenfrage da ist beispielsweise
die Islamisten in dem Sechser Bündnis
dagegen dass man die istanbula
Konvention wieder wieder Beitritt oder
nehmen Sie außenpolitische Fragen oder
weil beispielsweise die Flüchtlingsfrage
da ist man noch ganz uneins aber man hat
den gemeinsamen wilden jetzt Präsident
Erdogan abzuwählen und das kann glaube
ich auch im Moment nur die richtige
Strategie sein erstmal sozusagen
Präsident Erdogan
abzuwählen also first things first und
dann muss man natürlich weiter schauen
auch hier gilt der Satz der wohl so
Nahrung Gegner es geht nicht darum die
Toren zum Himmel zu öffnen sondern die
Toren zur Hölle endgültig zu schließen
jetzt haben sie skizziert warum diese
6er Bündnis schwierig ist lassen uns
vielleicht noch mal einen Blick an
dieser Stelle werfen auf die Kemalisten
alleine auf die CRP auf die Partei von
kemalu da wird ja oft so ein bisschen
der Eindruck vermittelt die CRP das ist
genau dasselbe wie die SPD in
Deutschland Kanzler Scholz Präsident
Klito das wäre irgendwie ein und
dasselbe ist es aber nicht oder nein das
ist es natürlich nicht die der
Kemalismus hat ja eine sehr lange
Tradition mit der Gründung der Türkei
und da muss merke mal Atatürk wurde die
kemalistische Ideologie sozusagen
etabliert und sie hat natürlich ein
sozialdemokratischen Ansatz aber es ist
nicht aus einer sozialdemokratischen
Bewegung heraus entstanden der
Kemalismus ist letztlich eine Ideologie
auch die ein Vorläufer hat mit den
jungtierten sehr starken nationalistisch
laizistisch geprägt geprägt ist aber
auch was die Chance jetzt für das
Sechser Bündnis ist auch pro westlich
deutlich sozusagen aktientiert ihre
Außenpolitik und das hat auch größere
deutlich gemacht er möchte ein Pro
westlichen europäischen Kurs fahren und
ist das ist glaube ich auch eine große
Chance für Europa hier sozusagen mit den
Kemalisten der CRP Unterführung von
Christina die Türkei wieder zu
europäisieren und zu verbessern
danke für den Moment Professor
hat gerade gesagt nationalistisch
geprägt die CRP vielleicht ist das auch
der Grund warum sie wahrscheinlich in
gewissen
Sichtweisen anders tickt als die SPD in
Deutschland was die Frage der
Migrationspolitik angeht kann man hat
gesagt dass er in spätestens zwei Jahren
die syrischen Flüchtlinge beispielsweise
aus dem Land haben möchte und das war im
Wahlkampf großes Thema
unterwegs im anatolischen hinterlandner
der syrischen Grenze in der Provinz
Adiyaman hunderttausende Flüchtlinge
leben hier seit dem Krieg in ihrer
Heimat Syrien jahrelang hat Abdul Karim
mit seiner Familie gebraucht um
anzukommen sie hatten eine kleine
Wohnung Arbeit auf dem Bau dann kam das
Beten
[Musik]
wir sind an diese Situation gewöhnt denn
wir haben fünf Jahre lang in einem Zelt
gelebt für die Türken ist das sicher
schwerer aber wir sind daran gewöhnt
Abdul Karim und seine Familie werden in
der Türkei geduldet 3,6 Millionen Syrer
sollen im Land leben das könnte sich
aber bald ändern die Rückführung der
Syrer im türkischen Wahlkampf ein
bestimmtes Thema
etwa 550.000 Flüchtlinge aus unserem
Land sind in die Region zurückgekehrt
die wir vom Terrorismus befreit und
sicher gemacht haben da wir seit einiger
Zeit diplomatischen Kontakt mit Russland
und Syrien unterhalten hoffen wir dass
diese Zahlen noch weiter steigen werden
die schlechte wirtschaftliche Lage in
der Türkei verschärft die ressortiments
gegen die Flüchtlinge so setzt auch die
Opposition auf das Thema
ja wir haben syrische Geschwister das
betone ich auch aber spätestens in zwei
Jahren ich sage das ohne Rassismus ohne
Rassismus werden wir in zwei Jahren
unsere syrischen Brüder in ihr eigenes
Land zurückschicken
ein Schlag ins Gesicht auch für die die
mittlerweile die türkische
Staatsbürgerschaft haben ein syrisches
theaterkollektivprobt in Istanbul trotz
Ausweis und offizieller Arbeitserlaubnis
erleben Sie täglich Schikanen
Verhaftungen sagen sie gehören zu ihrem
Alltag erst vor fünf Tagen wurde ich
wieder von der Polizei verhaftet und uns
Gefängnis gesteckt obwohl ich eine
Arbeitserlaubnis für Istanbul habe
trotz Staatsbürgerschaft gehöre ich
einfach nicht dazu es gibt niemanden in
diesem Land der mich verteidigt
zurück in Anja man nahm der türkisch
syrischen Grenze freiwillig werde er
nicht nach Syrien zurückkehren noch auch
wenn das bedeutet dass er und seine
Familie wieder Jahre im Zelt ausharren
müssen
der Kampf um die Zahlen bei den
Präsidentschaft und Parlamentswahlen in
der Türkei geht weiter und wir haben für
Sie aktuelle Zahlen an dieser Stelle
zunächst die aktuellen Zahlen von der
der Opposition etwas näher stehende
Nachrichtenagentur Anker da
zeichnet sich es inzwischen so ab
Präsident Erdogan liegt bei 48% der
Stimmen nach ungefähr 80% ausgezählter
Wahlurnen geh mal klitor sein Konkurrent
liegt bei 45%, also da noch ein Kopf an
Kopf rennen und wir gucken uns auch
wieder die Zahlen der Anadolu
Nachrichtenagentur an der etwas dem
Regierungslager nahe stehenden Agentur
da sieht es gerade so aus Receiver
Erdogan der amtierende Präsident bei 50%
bei 43,79%
. meine Vorlage für einen weiteren Blick
in die Türkei nach Ankara zu unserem
Korrespondenten Markus Rosch ich grüße
Sie
hallo ein echter Wahl Krimi ihre
Kollegin Katharina Willinger hat heute
geprägt den Begriff oder die
Begrifflichkeit des Kampf um die Zahlen
wie nehmen sie diesen Kampf um die
Zahlen war und wo stehen wir da aktuell
ja der Kampf der Zahlen tobt schon
seitdem die
Wahlbüros zu sind seit dem gezählt wird
seitdem die Zahlen auch veröffentlicht
werden und da war es ganz erstaunlich
wie auch schon vor fünf Jahren am Anfang
lag Präsident Erdogan im staatlichen
Fernsehen weit vorne Beachtung 50%, das
hat immer weiter abgenommen mittlerweile
sind wir fast bei einem Party nach 80%
der ausgezählten Stimmen die Opposition
zählt etwas anders es ist auf alle Fälle
klar es wird sehr sehr knapp es riecht
nach einer Stichwahl beide lagerfeiern
ich stehe hier vor der AKP Zentrale in
Ankara da fahren seit Stunden Autos
mitfahren mit musikem Hupens und feiern
den Sieg das ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen trotz die Zahlen nämlich
mitnehmen für die AKP ab also es ist ein
Kampf der Zahlen es riecht nach
Stichwahl das Endergebnis wird noch
etwas dauern es wird noch gezählt wie
gesagt 80% der Stimmen sind
ein bisschen deutlicher sieht das
Ergebnis ja aus wenn wir uns die
Verhältnisse bei den Parlamentswahlen
oder bei der Parlamentswahl anschauen da
liegt das Bündnis rund um die AKP doch
ein paar Meter vielleicht so gesprochen
deutlicher vorne was bedeutet das denn
wie sehr bedingt das eine auch das
andere das Ergebnis der
Präsidentschaftswahl das Ergebnis der
Parlamentswahl und umgekehrt
ja auch da ist ein Kampf der Zahlen
Istanbul ist zum Beispiel noch nicht
ganz ausgezählt da könnte die CRP
vorliegen wie es momentan aussieht hat
die AKP und ihr Partner die nationalen
rechtsnationale Map eine deutliche
Mehrheit im Parlament das könnte
natürlich falls Kilic tarolo in einer
Stichwahl vielleicht Präsident werden
würde die Arbeit natürlich erschweren
denn das Parlament kann blockieren und
Kilic stadulo hat ja auch gesagt er
möchte zurück zur parlamentarischen
Demokratie also kein ein Mann System
mehr da braucht er das Parlament und das
abzuschaffen und wenn das dann so wäre
bräuchte auch das Parlament um zurück um
regieren zu können also ähm da sind noch
eine Menge Fallstrecke man muss das
Ergebnis abwarten man muss eine mögliche
Stichwahl abwarten es ist klar es wird
insgesamt heute und vermutlich auch die
nächsten Tage und vermutlich auch die
nächsten zwei Wochen sehr sehr spannend
in der Türkei und die politischen Lager
stehen sich sehr unversöhnlich gegenüber
aber angesprochen was gerade rund um sie
passiert wir haben das gerade auch
während Ihrer Antwort gehört und gesehen
ein autokur so Hupen haben wir auch
gehört die akp-anhänger die aus Trotz
feiern haben sie gesagt jetzt gab es so
ein bisschen die Befürchtung im Vorfeld
je nachdem wie diese Wahl ausgeht könnte
das auch für eine sehr aggressive
Stimmung sorgen für eine Art Aufstand
vielleicht aber sowas da sind wir gerade
aktuell weit entfernt von oder
naja wir sind momentan weit entfernt
weil es halt so eine Art Situation gibt
aber wenn jetzt z.B vorentraten die CRP
für die Bürgermeister von Istanbul und
ähm Ankara vor die Kamera und die haben
gesagt kilica Rolo liegt vorne und das
muss man sich vielleicht mal vorstellen
wenn jetzt plötzlich nachdem Erdogan im
regierungsnahen Medien erst 58% hat er
abnehmend und jetzt plötzlich Killer
vielleicht gewinnen würde das würde den
Anhänger hier sicherlich nicht gefallen
also insofern ist die Lage immer noch
stabil gerade sie ist aber labil wie
gesagt es hängt jetzt von den Zahlen ab
vom Ergebnis ab ähm und das wird in ein
zwei Stunden sicherlich da sein und dann
muss dieses Ergebnis interpretiert
werden von den verschiedenen Lagern und
dann muss man mal weiter gucken aber
momentan ist es ruhig in der Tat und sie
haben das weiter für uns im Blick vielen
Dank für das Gespräch Markus Rosch noch
Ankara
wir haben es gerade gehört vom Kollegen
in Ankara labile Situation es ist
halbwegs ruhig noch da wo er gerade
steht wenn dann vielleicht doch am Ende
sich abzeichnen sollte das Thema Kilic
stardolo der Wahlsieger vielleicht auch
mit einer absoluten Mehrheit sein sollte
könnte es vielleicht aber nicht mehr so
ruhig bleiben hat er gesagt wie ist denn
da ihre Erwartungshaltung wie würde die
AKP wie würde Präsident Erdogan damit
umgehen wenn am Ende des Abends dieses
Ergebnis so stehen würde geh mal Kilic
stardolo absolute Mehrheit
da kommt es darauf an wie die absolute
Mehrheit aussieht also wenn die absolute
Mehrheit bei
50,005 oder 50,01 aussieht also knapp
die 50 Prozent Kämmer kirscht darüber
erhält dann kann ich mir durchaus
vorstellen dass Präsident Erdogan die
Wahl nicht akzeptieren wird und mit
aller Macht versuchen wird gegen diesen
Wahlsieg von Kemal Cristiano anzugehen
aber wenn der
Vorsprung
oder deutlich sozusagen über der 51%
liegt dann gehe ich davon aus dass
Präsident Erdogan hier auch die Wahl
akzeptieren wird und äh sozusagen
zurücktreten wird jeden Teil beigetragen
Herr Schuppe zu diesem Wahlergebnis
haben auch die Stimmberechtigten Deutsch
Türken 1,5 Millionen an der Zahl wie
viele genau abgestimmt haben und von
ihrem Wahlrecht Gebrauch gemacht haben
das wissen wir glaube ich noch nicht es
werden nicht wenige gewesen sein und wie
die Stimmungslage die Gemütslage unter
den Deutschtürken vor dieser Wahl
gewesen ist ich würde es mal mit
angespannt umreißen
an kaum einem anderen Ort schlägt
Berlins Herz so türkisch wie hier
Kreuzberg Cottbusser Tor eine
Institution das Kaffee
bei Ercan haben sie schon viel
diskutiert über die Politik in der
Türkei zwei der Männer in diesem
Nachmittag sind sich sicher Erdogan wird
wiedergewählt als Staatspräsident
er wird das also mindestens 53 Prozent
wieder der Welt mindestens
er reagiert sein statt sehr gut also wir
also die Leute haben
bessere Wohnung schöne Auto schön
erleben
die haben alles ich sage 56 oder
58%, 100 % bis morgen können die
Auslands Türken noch wählen in der
Vergangenheit stimmte die Mehrheit von
ihnen für Erdogan und seine Partei die
AKP dieses Mal aber könnte es knapp
werden für den türkischen
Staatspräsidenten die Umfragen besagen
dass es so eine Kopf an Kopf Rennen wird
aber weiß ich nicht also wir sind alle
gespannt
Erdogans Popularität bröckelt wegen des
verheerenden Erdbebens der Inflation der
stockenden Wirtschaft Probleme die auch
bei den Türken in Deutschland ankommen
ich lebe hier in Demokratie und kann ich
nicht die Augen zu machen wo kann sie
verwandeln in der Türkei ein Anti
demokratische Land leben wir wollen halt
eben eine Veränderung haben und deswegen
gehen
natürlich ist gegen
Menschlichkeit der Kandidat der
Oppositionspartei CRP könnte also
Chancen haben Erdogan abzulösen Kemal
Kilic storolo hier auf dem Flyer führt
ein Bündnis aus sechs Parteien an die
Stimmung am kurzfristig angemieteten
Wahlkampfbüro in Berlin hoffnungsvoll
und kämpferisch dieser ein Mann Regime
soll definitiv gehen und das
unterstützen wir hier jetzt auch und ich
hoffe dass alle uns mit unterstützen
werden noch 2014 war Erdogan persönlich
in Köln um die Auslandstürken solche
Massenveranstaltungen sind hier längst
verboten in diesem Jahr war die AKP aber
auch auf der Straße kaum unterwegs ihr
Wahlkampf ungewöhnlich leise das
beunruhigt viele in der türkischen
Gemeinschaft
natürlich haben wir sorgen natürlich
haben wir Ängste dass er so ruhig ist
macht uns natürlich Angst weil es muss
irgendwas kommen Erdogan wird nicht so
einfach diese Wahl verlieren so
schwappen die Probleme und die
Polarisierung in der Türkei auch nach
Deutschland
Sorgen und Ängste in der
deutsch-türkischen Community Herr
chopour wir haben sie das in den
vergangenen Tagen und Wochen
wahrgenommen wie dieses Thema Wahl in
der Türkei in dieser deutsch-türkischen
Community diskutiert wurde auch ja es
war sehr angespannt auch hier in
Deutschland die AKP hat ja relativ früh
mit dem Wahlkampf hier angefangen
beispielsweise mit der hessischen Rede
des AKB Abgeordneten in Neuss das heißt
es gab schon Spannungen und auch
Konflikte auch in Deutschland zu
beachten in europäischen Ländern gab es
Ausschreitungen Straßenkämpfe vor den
Konsulaten also es war sozusagen eine
sehr angespannte Situation es war auch
ein undercover Wahlkampf der AKP der
hier stattgefunden hat der massiv
natürlich auch durch die Türkei und
durch die AKP unterstützt worden ist
durch die die Moscheen aber auch durch
akpion wie die UID und ich gehe jetzt
auch davon aus dass Präsident Erdogan
hier in Deutschland ähm
die sozusagen
Endergebnis die Nase vorn haben wird im
Gegensatz zu klüterol das hat natürlich
verschiedene Gründe
das Deutschtürken hier verstärkt Erdogan
wählen es ist nicht nur gleich es ist
nicht nur eine Wahl an der sie sich für
die Türkei beteiligen sondern es ist
auch eine Botschaft an Deutschland die
AKP Anhänger und Anhänger hier gerne
loswerden möchten denn sie leben
einerseits in ihrer türkischen Blase die
durch die AKP Medien hier in Deutschland
auch verbreitet wird sie kriegen die AKP
Propaganda mit aber auch die islamischen
nationalistische Erziehung in den
Familien und nicht zu vergessen die
Ausgrenzungen Diskriminierung und damit
sozusagen geben sie auch deutlich
Deutschland zu Kenntnis dass das eine
Protest und trotz Wahl sein wird und
auch Deutschland eine Quittung mit einem
Denkzettel dafür geben für das was sie
in Deutschland erleben jetzt finde ich
persönlich immer wieder ganz spannend
das was Sie gesagt haben auf der einen
Seite Deutschland der Hut Zuspruch für
Präsident Erdogan und die AKP wenn wir
dann zum Beispiel in die Vereinigten
Staaten gucken wo ja auch
Menschenleben mit türkischen
Migrationshintergrund und die auch
wahlberechtigt sind bei den Wahlen in
der Türkei da fällt es oft ganz anders
aus das weil Ergebnis da ist der
Zuspruch für Erdogan wiederum nicht so
groß warum gibt es diesen Unterschied
zwischen deutschtürkten und US Türken
ist glaube ich dann der richtige
Terminus das hat mit der strukturellen
Zusammensetzung der türkei-stimmigen
komische in Deutschland zu tun also die
deutsch-stück in Deutschland das sind
jetzt keine Akademikerinnen und
Akademiker mehrheitlich die nach
Deutschland eingewandert sind sondern
insbesondere AKP Anhängerin die kommen
aus der schwarzen Region aus ländlichen
Gebieten aus Anatolien sind er
Bildungsfernsehen orientiert und in den
anderen Ländern die sie aufgezählt haben
also in den Vereinigten Staaten in
Kanada aber auch in skandinavischen
Ländern ist die Zusammensetzung der
Türkei stehen im Community eine völlig
andere das sind ja hochgebildete
hochqualifizierte sozusagen
Wissenschaftler zum Teil auch
intellektuelle die dort leben aber
beispielsweise wenn sie sich in
Skandinavien anschauen
zu sehr hohe kurdische Community die
dort sozusagen verstärkt natürlich die
HDP und die brokkolische Partei wählt
ich will auf einen anderen Punkt noch
kommen den sie eben angesprochen haben
den Wahlkampf der AKP in Deutschland der
ja vor fünf Jahren extrem polarisiert
hat wo es viele öffentliche Auftritte
gab der auch vor sechs Jahren als es um
das Referendum ging zur
Verfassungsänderung auch sehr
polarisiert hat das war schon in
gewisser Weise auch eine Änderung oder
eine neue Strategie die die AKP da in
diesem Jahr gefahren ist oder
tatsächlich das war ein Strategie Wandel
es gab jetzt nicht mehr die großen
Auftritte die waren ja nun mal verboten
oder mussten vorher genehmigt werden das
ist die AKP geschickt und unterlaufen
durch verschiedene
bürgerveranstaltungen oder beim
Fastenbrechen hat man auch deutsche
Politiker zu eingeladen und hat hier
gemeinsam mit der mit akp-abgeordneten
in Moscheen auch diese Moscheen
instrumentalisiert und von diesen von
den Moscheen heraus sind natürlich auch
die die Busse sozusagen zu den
Wahllokalen organisiert worden durch die
AKP also sehr zentralistisch sehr gut
organisiert hat die AKP hier unter dem
Radar der deutschen Öffentlichkeit im
Prinzip ein sehr effektiven Wahlkampf
geführt und von diesem Thema Herr Schuco
von der AKP und wie sie in Deutschland
Wahlkampf geführt hat kommen wir zum
staatlichen türkischen Fernsehen so eng
ist das da miteinander verknüpft AKP und
TRT ich glaube das darf ich an dieser
Stelle so sagen nicht zuletzt weil es
Untersuchung darüber gegeben hat was den
Wahlkampf angeht wie viel Anteil hat die
Regierung bekommen in der
Berichterstattung wie viel Anteil hat
die Opposition bekommen einen
Online-Portal hat er ausgewertet dass
allein Präsident Erdogan über 48 Stunden
in den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen zu
hören und zu sehen gewesen ist sein
kontraind heute Kemal Kilic noch nicht
mal eine Stunde am Stück ich glaube das
spricht für sich eine deutliche Sprache
ohne dass ich noch was dazu hinzufügen
hinzufügen müsste nichtsdestotrotz wir
schalten jetzt wieder auf das
original auf die Wahlsendung vom
staatlichen türkischen Sender TRT und
wollen uns angucken wie die Wahl wie
dieser Wahlabend aktuell dort gesehen
und bewertet wird
schon
im Moment
was wir im Moment benötigen oder sehen
müssen ist dass die Auszählungen nun
weitergehen und das müssen wir wirklich
gelassen machen und die Ergebnisse
abwarten und wie auch meine Vorredner
sagten ist es so dass die Mehrheit im
türkischen Parlament mit deiner
Wahrscheinlichkeit bei dem Bündnis von
Erdogan liegen wird und das ist insofern
diese Wahlen sind insofern auch wichtig
weil wir nun die Führung unseres Landes
wählen und
wir sehen dass Herr Erdogan mit plus
eine Stimme quasi 50 Prozent plus eins
gewählt wird aber auch der Abstand
zwischen Erdogan und Kovac als dem
nächst näheren Kandidaten da können wir
sehen dass es eine Stichwahl geben wird
zwischen den beiden und dieser große
Abstand wird wohl auch bei der Stichwahl
nicht zu schließen sein können wir sagen
und diese Situation zeigt uns dass der
Wille des Volkes für die Führung des
Landes in den kommenden fünf Jahren
bei
dann liegt das dieser Wille
ausgesprochen wurde und ich denke dass
das in den kommenden Tagen auch noch mal
deutlicher geklärt wird
ich möchte auch einen Satz dazu sagen
die
Berechnung von Chris charolo hier eine
verstärkte gestärkte parlamentarische
System
einzuführen und diese dieser Wille
der ist
zusammengebrochen und das
Präsidialsystem wird weitergeführt
mich
das
parlamentarische System
das war ein ganz wichtiges Argument von
Chris Shadow in den Wahlen nun sieht man
aber
das ist nicht dazu kommen wird dass das
Parlament keine solche Möglichkeit haben
wird die nationalistische neapie
wurde unter 6% gezeigt aber jetzt sehen
wir dass sie sogar über 10% ist
kann sie nun ganz hören ich beginne mit
Ihrer Frage hinsichtlich der MHP ich
hatte das vorhin auch schon diese Frage
beantwortet in den letzten Wochen bei
den vor Umfragen
war wurde eigentlich sehr viel weniger
erwartet insbesondere die
Reden von Herrn bei den letzten
Kundgebungen und keine aus seiner
Auftritte dort
haben nun auch dazu beigetragen also es
war wirklich
überraschend dass die MHP nun doch mehr
Stimmen bekommen hat hat als vorher
gesagt wurde und die Frage
ob die MHP gewählt wird das haben die
Wähler nun beantwortet und sie haben
ihre Stimmen für die MHP abgegeben und
wenn
in Bezug auf die Stärkung des
parlamentarischen Systems zu kommen es
gab sehr viele Vorwürfe
im Vorfeld und bis äh diese Situation im
Parlament wieder geklärt wird geordnet
wird ob man das Land überhaupt regieren
kann oder nicht es wurde eine
Unsicherheit gesehen und das war
natürlich auch nicht überraschend sowohl
die Welt als auch die Türkei geht nun
durch eine sehr kritische Zeit und für
die WählerInnen und Spieler war das auch
eine schwierige Situation weil sie auch
im Prinzip unsicher waren und nicht
wussten was passieren wird aber wir
können sehen dass das folgt doch Herrn
Erdogan das Vertrauen ausgesprochen hat
und
nicht nur hinsichtlich der Stärken des
parlamentarischen Systems aber auch
hinsichtlich anderer politischer Themen
konnten wir sehen dass das volksbündnis
nicht das Vertrauen der
wählerinnenfehler bekommen hat bei dem
bei der Sechser Koalition gab es
politische Krisen und sie hat noch keine
politische Lösungen anzubieten den den
wir darin und Wählern und sie haben
Behauptungen aufgestellt die sie aber
nicht mit Inhalt füllen konnten und das
hat natürlich auch die Fehler
beeinflusst vielen dank vielen Dank ich
möchte mit weitermachen von der Zeitung
wenn wir 2018
die Wahlergebnisse schauen der muharren
Ince damaliger Kandidat der CHP
hat
andere Ergebnisse bekommen und Salat in
demmeltasche hat ein Ergebnis bekommen
momentan 44 % bekommen
Sie uns erklären was diese
unterschiedlichen Zahlen und sagen
spricht jetzt gerade
gespielt
es sind 15% der Auslands zu Stimmen
gezählt worden und
da sind wir vorne und ähm
da wurden eher Säcke aufgefüllt und das
sind vier
Wahlurnen entsprechend vier Wahlurnen
und deswegen
dauert es es auch etwas es geht aber
nicht darum dass das so lahmt sondern es
geht natürlich darum dass der nationale
Wille
zum Ausdruck gebracht wird und wir haben
bis zum Morgen Zeit beim letzten Mal
wurden die auslandsstimmen
nachts um 3 Uhr gezählt und es ist
natürlich nicht zu behaupten dass es zu
langsam geht es muss weitergemacht
werden und wir hoffen dass es auch hier
weitergeht und auch die Stimmen die aus
dem ländlichen Regionen kommen werden
natürlich auch in die Ergebnisse
einfließen und letztendlich wird es in
den nationalen Willen in den Volkes
willen einfließen und wird für die
Türkei gut sein
gibt es Probleme oder was ist los nein
Freunde hier passiert dir nichts
außergewöhnlich es ist alles ganz normal
es ist eine normale Routine an dem
Wahlurnen sind Vertreter der Parteien es
sind Wahlbeobachter da es sind Vertreter
der Wahlkommission da und jede Wahlurne
hat auch einen Wahlurnen Chef sozusagen
also die schwimmen werden ganz normal
ausgezählt warten Sie bitte das Ergebnis
ab wie viele Widersprüche gibt es
eigentlich also es ist so
wenn Sie das jetzt in den Vordergrund
stellen einige Teile sprechen einige
Leute sprechen von Widersprüchen aber es
ist wirklich nicht so dass nun ganz
besonders viele Widersprüche vorhanden
sind
[Musik]
an den wahlordnen gibt es natürlich
wahlberichte also es stimmt Listen und
die werden kontrolliert und wenn nun da
große Unterschiede auftauchen dann wird
Widerspruch eingelegt und bis morgen bzw
bis Dienstag 15 Uhr haben alle die
Möglichkeit haben die Parteien die
Möglichkeit Widerspruch eingelegt zu
werden und wir sind nun dabei die
Widersprüche
vorzubereiten bzw zu prüfen also sie
rufen die Bevölkerung zu Geduld haben ja
aber natürlich wir rufen die Bevölkerung
zu Geduld auf das Ende wird wunderbar
sein ja wir haben gerade Alice sein
Yavuz live gehört an unserem Bildschirm
und in unserem Istanbuler Studio ist der
[Musik]
Chefredakteur der aksam Zeitung und ihm
frage ich nach dem Performance nach der
Performance im Moment von wenn wir nun
mit 2018 die Dynamiken mit heute
vergleichen was sehen wir
natürlich
erkläre schauen Sie sich die Stimmen
Prozente an das ist ein kein
erfolgsbild sondern es ist ein
erfolgloses Bild und es zeigt keinen
Erfolg und wenn wir dieses auch auf
Partei Basis betrachten
dass das nicht gerade für die
gut gelaufen ist mit 44,1%
der Grund dafür ist der
wir hatten erwähnt dass die Chefin der
e-party Meral actional vom 6er
bündnistisch aufgestanden war und drei
Tage später wieder zurückkam gab es
einen Erdbeben in an dem Tisch und
danach wurde dieses Erdbeben auch in
Richtung
weitergeleitet und
waren Ince hat dann auch erklärt er war
seit 50 60 Tagen unter schweren
Beschluss und ähm
da hat man die
[Musik]
zurückgetreten ist sie konnte man sich
denken dass ein Teil der Stimmen an
Sinan Organ gegangen ist und der hatte
2,5% ungefähr und die sind jetzt mal
über fünf Prozent gekommen und
wir sehen auch dass bei den
geöffneten Urnen bei den ausgezählten
Stimmen auch eine gewisse Stabilität
herrscht
wir sehen kein
Erhöhung momentan der Stimmen für die
Cap und für die e-party in der in den
Bündnis und auch bei den kleineren
linken Parteien sehen wir auch dass sie
erwarteten Ergebnisse nicht erzielt
wurden
und die Einsprüche
das habe ich vorher auch gesagt
der
das
Bündnis mit Erdogan ist natürlich
selbstbewusst in die Wahlen gegangen und
ist
mit dem mit der Voraussage von 57%
gestartet und
das
Bündnis von Cristiano oder aber das
haben sie nicht erreicht das sehen wir
und wir haben gerade gehört über die
auslandsstimmen dass sie nur zu 15
Prozent gezählt wurden und insgesamt
wurden aber jetzt von den Stimmen 87%
gezählt wurden und davon sind ungefähr
50,0% der Erdogan und 44%
nun haben wir hier den Vorsitzende der
war der Wahlkommission der hohen
Wahlkommission der nun hier sprechen
wird
ist der Vorsitzende der hohen
Wahlkommission sehr geehrte
Pressevertreter ich begrüße Sie ganz
herzlich
wir haben bisher wir konnten bisher
keine Verspätung und keine Probleme
verzeichnen und die Daten die
Informationen werden nun auch
von den Parteien veröffentlichten
mitgeteilt
von den 24 Parteien sind angetreten wir
haben sowohl von den Kreis als auch von
den Provinz Wahlkommissionen
Informationen bekommen und im Moment
können wir folgendes sagen
47,08 im Land
12,60 ähm
Prozent aus dem Stimmen aus dem Ausland
konnten bisher verzeichnet werden sehr
geehrte Freunde
wir wissen sehr genau und auch
gesetzlich ist festgelegt wie bei
Verspätung bei den Auszählungen
umzugehen ist
gut das war Ahmed jänner der Vorsitzende
der hohen Wahlkommission sehr geehrte
Zuschauer und diese Informationen werden
den Abend durch und die Nacht durch
aktualisiert werden und im Hinblick auf
diese Daten auf der Grundlage diese
Daten möchte ich gerne Herrn Karl noch
mal das Wort geben
[Musik]
ich habe es nicht verstanden dass was er
hohe
wahlkommissionsvorsitzende gesagt hat
das sind natürlich bisschen niedrige
Zahlen die ich da sehe
aber es gibt natürlich noch mal die
[Musik]
Wahlergebnisse die die Parteien bekommen
von ihren eigenen Netzwerken die sind
natürlich sehr viel höher und vielleicht
ist die Wahlkommission da etwas
vorsichtiger mit der Erklärung
jetzt natürlich der
wahlkommissionsvorsitzende achmedizin
hat gesagt in der im Inland sind 47,8 %
und im Ausland 12,6 % gezählt worden das
war eine sehr schwierige Wahl wir sind
als attackerbündnis in die Wahlen
gegangen und wir wurden sowohl in den
Fernsehsendern als auch bei den Umfragen
ignoriert wir wurden angegriffen wir
würden sogar mit Stöcken und Steinen
angegriffen in sozialen Medien Kolumnen
Fernsehsendungen wurden wir regelrecht
gelöscht dennoch haben wir uns an
unserem Plan gehalten und vom seit dem
ersten Tag haben wir folgendes gesagt
bei diesen Wahlen
werden wir
werden Parteien
die mit Terrororganisation wie HDP und
twitterpark koalieren
treten an und wir werden dagegen
antreten haben wir gesagt und unter
diesem Bedingungen ist es natürlich
nicht sehr einfach bei den bisschen die
Stichwahlen zu kommen allerdings haben
wir etwas anderes schaffen können
es war natürlich von Anfang an klar dass
es Stichwahl gibt also dass ein zweiten
Wahlgang geben wird aber wir türkischen
Nationalisten
wollten dass das dass die türkische
Nationalisten im Zentrum der Wahlen in
der Türkei sind und
die es geht um die Interessen unseres
Landes und die türkischen Nationalisten
schützen die Interessen dieses Landes
das wollten wir zeigen und wie es
aussieht wird es eine zweite Wahlrunde
geben wir haben gerade die Erklärung des
hohen der hohen Wahlkommission gehört
und wir haben gehört dass etwa
Prozent der
Wahlurnen im Land in der Türkei
eingespeist wurden in die Ergebnisse und
aus dem Ausland 12 Prozent und wir sehen
auch wenn wir uns die verschiedenen
Agenturen ansehen unterschiedliche
Ergebnisse aber es ist eins ist klar
dass die türkischen Nationalisten die
atatürkanhänger
ausschlaggebend sein werden in der
zweiten Wahlrunde sehr geehrte Zuschauer
wir haben 15 weitere schwierige Tage vor
uns und in diesen weiteren 15 Tagen
natürlich wenn die Wahlen heute und die
Auszählung heute Abend abgeschlossen
werden und eine zweite Runde notwendig
sein wird werden wir alles tun was in
unserer Macht steht damit wir ein
Ergebnis zum Wohl unseres Landes
erreichen werden und wir werden auch
nicht sagen dass wir den einen oder
anderen von den Kandidaten unterstützen
aber gemeinsam mit dem Parteien die in
dem Alter Bündnis sind
wir werden uns beraten mit den anderen
Parteien in unserem Bündnis und infolge
dieser Beratung dann uns Äußern von
Anfang an haben wir folgende Haltung an
den Tag gelegt und zwar in den letzten
Tagen war das so als würden wir
in Verhandlungen gehen mit einem der
Bündnis aber das ist nicht richtig wir
gehen davon aus dass die ersten vier
Artikel unserer Verfassung unveränderbar
sind und das Artikel 66 auch
wichtig ist dass 13 Millionen
Flüchtlinge zurückgeschickt werden
müssen dass die dass das türkenturm
geschützt werden muss und auch dass die
Wirtschaftspolitik dass die hohe
Inflation
ein wichtiges Thema ist und wir haben
wichtige Erwartungen
und Bedingungen die wir stellen wenn wir
ein Wahlempfehlung aussprechen in der
zweiten Runde vergessen wir nicht dass
der dass die Bekämpfung des Terrors sehr
wichtig ist
ja und wir sind zurück im Phönix Studio
Sinan One hat gerade gesprochen im
türkischen Fernsehen der
spitzenkandidatop-kandidat der Ultra
Rechten des ultrarechten ATA Bündnisses
darüber würde ich sprechen über diese
Person auch mit Professor Burak was
können wir uns denn vorstellen für diese
Stichwahl die ja möglicherweise dann in
zwei Wochen stattfindet wenn wir uns
jetzt halten an die Zahlen der
oppositionsnah Nachrichtenagentur Anker
sieht es so aus als ob weder Erdogan
noch Kilic Stahl solo die absolute
Mehrheit heute erreichen hieße wir gehen
in zwei Wochen in den Stichwahl die
Stimmen die Sinan Ohren der Kandidat der
rechtsextreme bekommen hat während
wieder auf dem Markt sozusagen
und wer bekommt die dann hier das ist
eben die große Frage ich bin leider
sozusagen kein Hellseher habe auch keine
Glaskugel hier im Studio sondern bin
Politikwissenschaftler das wird die
große Frage sein wohin werden die
Wählerinnen und Wähler der das Atta
Bündnisses sozusagen wandern und wie
wird sich vor allem Dingen auch Sinan
Ohren und Professor mit özda der ja
sozusagen eine Abspaltung ist von der
BHP also ein Ex mehr Fehler ist dann die
ehepartei gegründet hat mit Melan Action
und dann sich wieder abgespalten hat und
die siegespartei die Sache Partei
gegründet hat und professionell da der
auch in Deutschland der studiert hat ist
ein ganz kleiner Hardliner einen
Rechtsextremismus
mit extrem rassistischen Ansichten was
die Flüchtlingsfrage beispielsweise
angeht aber was auch die Kurden Frage
angeht und die werden natürlich den
Preis jetzt hochtreiben wenn es zu einer
Stichwahl kommt und entscheiden
Behinderten mit einer wird dann
natürlich sein wie sich Sinan Ohren und
Professor verhalten werden ob sie
tatsächlich einen Aufruf zu
Unterstützung von Kemal Christel machen
werden wenn sie generieren sie zeigen
sich als
Oppositionspartei nach außen hin aber es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass sie dann
Ohren und mit Öse da hier bei möglichen
Angeboten von Präsident Erdogan auch
sozusagen wechseln in das Bündnis von
Präsident er dann und das wäre natürlich
der Super-GAU für die Türkei wenn
Präsident Erdogan mit seinem Bündnis von
Islamisten radikal Islamisten unter der
hütterpaar extrem Rechtsextremisten der
Map dann auch noch Sinan Ohren und seine
rechtsextremistisches Atmen ist mit ins
Boot nimmt das würde letztlich bedeuten
für die Türkei und das ist keine Lösung
geben wird in diesen zentralen Fragen
wie Flüchtlingsfrage bzw auch der
Kurdenfrage wir haben gerade gesagt
hoher Preis was könnte denn auf der
Rechnung stehen für entweder Kilic
stardolo oder für Erdogan wenn sie sagen
würden wir machen da gemeinsame Sache
mit den Rechtsextremen mit Ohren und Co
naja also Präsident Erdogan kann ja hier
anbieten das Sinan Ohren und seine und
insbesondere auch immer hier ein eine
Stellvertretung bekommen als als
Präsident sagen ein der Vertreter des
Staatspräsidenten werden und andere
Ministerien ihn zugesprochen werden und
dann können Sie natürlich versuchen auch
die Flüchtlingsfrage mit Gewalt auch zu
lösen also das sind die vor deiner quasi
eine Deportation auch der der
Flüchtlinge in in Syrien und sie können
natürlich auch ein ganz knallharten Kurs
ein radikalen Kurs auch in der Kurden
Frage früher und das heißt
Kriminalisierung weiter der HDP und auch
weitere Bekämpfung der der Kurden in der
Türkei vorsichtige Vermutung von mir an
dieser Stelle herzschuppen liberaler
würde die Türkei dadurch nicht wenn sie
in an Ohren in der Regierung etwas zu
sagen hätte wenn die rechtsextrem da
einen hohen Preis für sich am Ende
rausschlagen können wir haben gerade
über die Kurden Frage gesprochen wir
haben gerade gesprochen auch über die
Flüchtlinge die aktuell in der Türkei
leben und so hat sie Schoko gerade
gesagt möglicherweise eine Deportation
dann erleben könnten eine andere Gruppe
die es ohnehin schon Schwert in der
Türkei sind die Frauen und auch was das
Thema Frauenrechte angeht könnte es
schwierig bleiben
Spuren einer Ehe
zuerst hat er mich ins Gesicht gestochen
so von hier nach da ich habe versucht
mich zu schützen dann hat er das Messer
in meiner Hand gestochen zweimal dreimal
es waren dreimal als ich das ganze Blut
gesehen habe hatte ich solche Angst
drei Monate ist das jetzt her heute
zeigt Melek ihre Familie zum ersten mal
was ihr Mann ihr angetan hat ein Gesetz
hat sie von noch mehr Gewalt gerettet so
konnte sie sofort mit den Kindern ins
Frauenhaus oder sofort eine einstweilige
Verfügung gegen den Ehemann erlassen
konnte Melek sofort die Scheidung
einreichen das Gesetz das schärfste
Schwert im Kampf gegen Gewalt an Frauen
wir die Staatsanwaltschaft und die
Polizei können sehr schnell nämlich
innerhalb von 24 Stunden eine
einstweilige Verfügung erwirken ohne
dass wir sofort Beweise für diese Gewalt
vorlegen müssen
doch dieses Gesetz könnte nun gekippt
werden im Wahlkampf haben Erdogans
Verbündete dem Präsidenten das
Einverständnis abgerungen dieses Gesetz
zu verändern
natürlich wollen wir sicherstellen dass
Frauen und Kinder geschützt werden aber
ohne dass dabei die Institution Familie
beschädigt wird
der Anwalt will die Männer schützen
vor dem Gesetz gilt doch dass jeder
unschuldig ist bis die Schuld bewiesen
ist wenn sie behaupten dass ich mir was
zu Schulden habe kommen lassen dann
müssen sie mir das beweisen
aber eine solche Überprüfung dauert und
diese Zeit hatte Melek nicht für sie
hätte es den Tod bedeutet da ist sich
die 25-Jährige sicher ich will nicht
erst beweisen müssen dass ich
misshandelt wurde bevor was getan wird
ich möchte dass sie mich als Frau
schützen ich will dass man meine Stimme
hört
wir betroffene Frauen geht es bei dieser
Wahl deshalb um mehr als nur den
Präsidenten es geht auch um Ihren
persönlichen Schutz
sollte Erdogan gewinnen haben wir Angst
denn jeder von uns könnte betroffen sein
wir hoffen auf Kölle starodo darauf dass
er zu uns Frauen steht
und sie hofft darauf dass ich die Türkei
dann wieder zum Schutz der Frauen
bekennt
Professor
was müssen die Frauen befürchten in der
Türkei gegebenenfalls bei einer
Regierungsbeteiligung in welcher Form
auch immer der rechtsextreme bei so
Themen beispielsweise wie Gewalt in der
Ehe auch in der Türkei ja für die Frauen
steht viel auf dem Spiel das wäre ein
Albtraum wenn Präsident Erdogan mit
seinem islamistischen Bündnis in denen
ja nicht nur diejenige der Lehrfach
Partei also die sozusagen der der Sohn
von nicht mit den Albert kann sozusagen
mit ihm ist sondern auch die radikal
islamistische hyperparty ja mal sagen
Terrororganisation war und sich jetzt
als Partei etabliert hat und in diesem
Bündnis von Präsident Erdogan ebenfalls
ist
Präsident erdogan ist ja bereits aus der
Istanbul Konventionen ausgetreten ist
gibt jetzt Diskussion dass das
frauenschutzgesetz 6.284 auch ebenfalls
sozusagen verändert werden soll in
während der AKP
ärger gab es 4000 femizide also es
verging kein Tag wo eigentlich Frauen
brutal erschossen worden sind auf den
Straßen kein keine Woche wo eben Frauen
angegriffen worden sind von ihren eh
Männern erschossen worden sind auf der
Straße die lttpd-bewegung wird bekämpft
und kriminalisiert durch dieses Bündnis
insofern ist das ist das ein ganz großer
Horror für die für die Frauen in der
Türkei aber man muss auch hier den der
Frauenbewegung zu gut halten sie
demonstrieren jede jedes Jahr sozusagen
am Weltfrauentag werden brutal auch
niedergeschlagen ihnen Demonstration und
sie haben nicht aufgegeben und die
Frauenbewegung ist in diese in dieser
Wahl ein entscheidender Faktor wenn
Christen oder die Wahl gewinnen sollte
düstere Aussichten also Herzschuppe
gegebenenfalls für die Frauen in der
Türkei wir wissen aber immer noch nicht
wie diese Wahl ausgehen wird wir haben
eben bevor wir sie dann Ohren gehört
hatten den Vorsitzenden
Kandidaten der rechtsextrem kurz auch
gehört ahmedianer den Vorsitzenden des
hohen wahlrates in der Türkei der einen
Stand abgegeben hat zu den Stimmen die
abgegeben wurden da hieß es da deutlich
weniger als zum Teil die Agenturen auf
ihren Webseiten veröffentlichen noch
nicht mal 50 Prozent die ausgezählt sind
der Stimmen im Inland noch deutlich
weniger der Stimmen die aus dem Ausland
gekommen sind also da wird noch viel
gezählt in der Türkei bis es da ein
Ergebnis gibt um jetzt wieder den Bogen
zu schlagen zu den Frauenrechten über
die wir gerade gesprochen haben wichtige
und
stimmungsstarke meinungsstarke laute
Stimme für die Frauen in Deutschland
zumindest ist die Linke
Parteivorsitzende Janine Wissler und es
gibt einige Stimmen zu diesem Wahlabend
zu diesem Wahlergebnisse aus Deutschland
schon die wir für sie vorliegen haben
unter anderem eben von Janine Wissler
unsere Hoffnung ist ganz klar dass die
Ära Erdogan endet dass demokratische
Grundrechte wiederhergestellt werden in
der Türkei und unsere Gedanken sind
heute Abend bei den demokratischen
Kräften in der Türkei und ganz besonders
bei der Party wo ja auch viele
Kandidierende der HDP auf den
listenantreten weil die HDP ja selber
nicht antreten konnte wir hoffen heute
Abend ja auf alle Kräfte die eine
soziale eine friedliche eine
demokratische Türkei wollen und
natürlich auch darauf dass die vielen
Inhaftierten frei kommen also die vielen
Abgeordneten Bürgermeisterin
Bürgermeister Journalisten die in
türkischen Gefängnissen sitzen und
völlig willkürlich verhaftet wurden auch
gerade in den Tagen vor dieser Wahl ja
hoffen sehr darauf dass das wirklich
heute abend diese schicksalsverhandelte
Türkei dass die demografischen Kräfte
daraus gestärkt hervorgehen das ist eine
Wahl die weit über die Türkei hinaus
Bedeutung hat und ich muss auch sagen
dass es auch ein Versagen ist der
Europäischen Union und auch
die führender PolitikerInnen Politiker
dass sie zu den
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in der Türkei
auch zu den militärischen Angriffen auf
die kurdischen Gebiete das dazu viel zu
viel geschwiegen wird dass das nicht
klar verurteilt wird und dass man mit
Nato-Partner Türkei da wirklich völlig
freie Hand lässt das ist ein Problem und
das habe ich auch festgestellt als ich
in der Türkei war dass viele
Oppositionelle sich doch da alleine
gelassen fühlen und sich wünschen würden
dass es hier auch deutlicher Worte gibt
von einer Außenministerin von einem
Bundeskanzler die immer von Werte
basierte Außenpolitik sprechen vom
feministische Außenpolitik und da fühlen
sich die Menschen schon sehr alleine
gelassen also von daher es ist wichtig
für Europa vor allem ist aber auch
wichtig dass führende Politiker der EU
klar also Flagge bekennen und eben nicht
wegschauen wenn NATO Staat wie die
Türkei eben völkerrechtswidrig
bombardieren und Menschenrechte mit
Füßen treten
die Türkei steht heute auf einer
riesengroßen Chance denn es gibt die
Chance eine autoritäre Führung zu
überwinden und einen großen Schritt
zurück zu Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu gehen ich drücke
allen demokratischen und Demokraten in
diesem Land heute die Daumen und
natürlich wäre das auch für die
deutsch-türkische Zusammenarbeit und für
die Rolle der Türkei in Europa ein
riesengroßer Schritt denn man könnte
wieder enger zusammenarbeiten aber
erstmal wäre es glaube ich eine große
Befreiung für viele Menschen im Land
dort wir schon mit großem Interesse auf
die Wahl in der Türkei weil die Türkei
ein wichtiges strategischer Partner ist
wie aber in den letzten Jahren viele
Probleme auch wahrnehmen mussten
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Pressefreiheit
Menschenrechtsfragen die Orientierung
die Haltung der Türkei in dem Ukraine
Krieg und ähm deshalb beobachten wir mit
Interesse den Wahlabend und dann die
Weichenstellungen die sich danach
ergeben fest steht die Partei Erdogan es
war grundsätzlich eine Partei die viele
Brücken nach Europa gesucht hat es hat
sich unter ihm anders entwickelt das
haben wir immer mit Sorge betrachtet da
gilt es Brücken zu bauen und inwieweit
ist dann mit der Opposition mit dem
Oppositionsbündnis möglich ist es wird
sich weisen ist jedenfalls die
Ankündigung gemacht werden dass man da
gesprächsfördern und Brücken suchen
möchte deshalb gibt es einfach den
heutigen Abend abzuwarten und wenn wir
sehr genau verfolgen wie die Weichen
gestellt werden ein großes Interesse an
der Frage wie entwickelt sich die Türkei
nimmt sie einen Weg wo Menschenrechte
geachtet Rechtsstaatlichkeit gestärkt
die Pressefreiheit eingehalten wird sie
hat Flüchtlinge aufgenommen sie hat
einen Erdbeben erlitten wir stehen zur
Partnerschaft aber wir hoffen dass die
Türkei sich wieder stärker zu Europa
wendet statt in eine andere Richtung das
Thema EU-Mitgliedschaft steht nicht auf
der Tagesordnung auf der Tagesordnung
steht aber die Frage einer Partnerschaft
auch einer privilegierten Partnerschaft
die wir an der Türkei anbieten und die
dann aber egal wie und egal mit welchem
Partner auch mit Leben gefüllt werden
muss von beiden Seiten
dafür ist die Voraussetzung ein ganz
klares commitment zur
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu Menschenrechte zu
einer Partnerschaft in Europa und
insofern richtet sich der Blick in die
Türkei richtet sich dann auch an die
Bundesregierung wo sie Möglichkeiten so
Zusammenarbeit sieht wo diese gestärkt
werden kann steht fest die Türkei hat
viele Flüchtlinge aufgenommen es ist von
Bedeutung dass die Partnerschaft hier
fortgeführt wird und wir jedenfalls gilt
für uns als Union für uns ja auch in
Deutschland sind dazu bereit auf dieser
Grundlage weiter zu arbeiten egal wer
gewinnt hat die Aufgabe Demokratie zu
stärken Pressefreiheit zu stärken
Menschenrechte zu stärken und wir
verbinden egal welche
Parteien Personen gewählt werden mit der
Zukunft die Hoffnung dass hier ein Weg
Richtung Europa nicht verbaut wird
sondern Brücken aufgebaut wird
neue Brücken die gebaut werden sollen
das ist es was sich die Politikerinnen
und Politiker die wir gerade gehört
haben wünschen Professor Burak chopo das
deutsch-türkische Verhältnis da wurden
in den vergangenen Jahren eher Brücken
eingerissen als aufgebaut und erhalten
das
Verhältnis so habe ich es vorhin mit
Claudia Roth ja auch besprochen erkaltet
eingefroren frostig wie schätzen Sie das
ein zum einen wenn killic stardolo
gewählt würde zum anderen wenn Erdogan
gewählt würde wie könnte sich das
deutsch-türkische Verhältnis jeweils
entwickeln ja also wenn Präsident
Erdogan gewählt wird dann wird es auch
ein weiter so in den deutschen
türkischen Beziehungen geben das heißt
die deutsche Beziehungen sind ja auf dem
Tiefpunkt man kann sich nicht vorstellen
dass Präsident Erdogan hier ähm
sozusagen ein Strategiewechsel in der
türkischen Deutschland Politik einleiten
wird dafür ist einfach auch zu viel
Porzellan kaputt gegangen erinnern uns
zurück an die Nazis vor Würfel von
Präsident Erdogan an Frauen an Frau
Merkel und sozusagen auch an seine
Äußerungen wie sehr er sozusagen den
Westen aber auch das Christentum im
Prinzip verachtet und auch herabschaut
auf auf die Europäische Union und das
wird in den deutsch-türkischen
Verhältnissen im Prinzip kein
Fortschritt sein und es wird immer auf
einer sehr realpolitischen und macht
opportunistischen
Strategie beruhen Präsident Erdogans
Beziehungen zu deutsch Deutschland aber
auch zu Europäischen Union das wird sich
denke ich aber mit kämmerkrüchten oder
ändern er hat sie ja ganz klar auch
signalisiert er möchte die
EU-Reform aufnehmen egal ob es für ihn
eine Perspektive für die Freundschaft
gibt oder nicht er versuchen die
Verhandlungskapitel selber sozusagen als
sozusagen
empfehlen hier gibt auch
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und eine unabhängige
Justiz wieder sozusagen aufzubauen im
Land aber das wird natürlich nicht
einfach sein denn auch hier muss
Wiederaufbau geleistet werden aber es
ist wichtig dass es das was auch Frau
Roth gesagt hat dass das Deutschland
insbesondere aber auch dann die
Europäische Union falls es zu einem
Machtwechsel kommt der Türkei die Hand
reichen muss sie unterstützen muss also
nicht mehr kleckern sondern klotzen in
den deutschen Beziehung ich kann mich in
dem Zusammenhang er zuvor gerade an
einer Aussage erinnern von Yunus
solosäure vom Zentrum für türkei-studien
der mir in dem Interview gesagt hat
Türkei und Deutschland diese beiden
Länder sind so eng miteinander verwoben
und stehen so eng Seite an Seite dass er
irgendwie Verwandte kein Ehepaar ein
Ehepaar kann sich scheiden lassen
Verwandte aber nicht Deutschland und die
Türkei das eine ohne das andere ist
nicht vorstellbar oder mit der Bitte um
eine kurze Antwort an der Stelle ja klar
also dieses diese beiden Länder
verbindet ja nicht nur eine Geschichte
sondern auch eben diese drei Millionen
Menschen auch die Gastarbeiter die hier
nach Deutschland kam das Land mit
aufgebaut haben und die Themen der
Integration spielen ja tagtäglich hier
eine Rolle und da ist natürlich die
Türkei ein wichtiger wichtiges Land es
kann zur mehr Integration beitragen aber
es kann auch dazu führen dass die
Menschen sich hier desintegrieren und
sich abwenden von von der deutschen
Gesellschaft und das ist in den letzten
Jahren eben passiert auch das gerade
alles noch ein bisschen auf der
spekulativen Ebene natürlich wie sich
dann im nächsten Schritt entwickeln wird
wir werden das Sehen Professor wir
sprechen gleich noch einmal an dieser
Stelle aber unsere dritte Schalter heute
in die Türkei nach Ankara zu Markus
Markus Rosch der weiter die diesen
Wahlkrimi für uns verfolgt den Kampf um
die Zahlen wir haben eben gehört Herr
roschetdiener den Vorsitzende des hohen
Wahlarzt der uns erzählt hat dass so
viele Stimmen wie uns das glauben
gemacht wird auf den Internetportal noch
gar nicht ausgezählt sind was haben wir
davon zu halten
also wir wissen dass 90 Prozent der
Wahlurnen schon geöffnet sind und vor
einer Minute ist die Erdogan gerade im
staatlichen Fernsehen unter 50 Prozent
gefallen wir wissen aber auch dass viele
Millionen Stimmen noch nicht ausgezählt
worden sind also es kann auch dauern es
kann auch zu Verschiebungen kommen aber
es sieht aus als würde keiner der
Kandidaten die 50% Marke im schaffen das
heißt es würde eigentlich es wird eine
Stichwahl in zwei Wochen geben so dieses
momentan aus aber es sind doch viele
viele Fragen offen die Opposition
beklagt das Wahlurnen in ihren starken
Bezirken dass da im Einspruch gegen die
Zählung erhoben worden ist das wurde
also noch nicht ausgezählt also es kann
sich durchaus noch verschieben im Laufe
des Tages das Ergebnis ist nicht sicher
aber es sieht nach einer Stichwahl aus
jetzt haben das glaube ich alle auch
endgültig verstanden 90 % geöffnet
Wahlurnen heißt noch nicht 90% mit der
Stimmen ausgezählt von daher eben dann
doch noch ein langer Abend für Sie in
Ankara für uns bei Phoenix auch ab 23
Uhr dann mit meinem Kollegen Marlon
amojal hier im Studio und natürlich auch
einen Blick dann auf die Türkei Wahl
Herr Rosch sie haben die mögliche
Stichwahl schon angesprochen wir haben
eben hier im Studio über die Rolle von
Sinan Ohren vom Kandidaten der
rechtsextremen geredet der ja auch fünf
Prozent bei 5% bis 6 Prozent gerade
liegt wie würde denn sozusagen diese
Anzahl oder diese Anteil von Stimmen am
Ende aufgeteilt haben sie da eine
Prognose für uns
hört sich noch nicht geäußert das ist
schwierig dass natürlich entscheidende
stimmen da muss das muss man abwarten
wie er sich dann entscheidet aber in der
Tat fünf Prozent könnte wirklich hier
die Präsidentschaft bedeuten die werden
müssen natürlich auch mitspielen sie
werden natürlich eher dem Präsidenten
zuneigen aber das sind Spekulationen da
muss man wirklich abwarten wie die
nächsten zwei Wochen auch laufen werden
wir wissen ja nicht was passiert es wird
wenn es dann eine Stichwahl gibt der
Präsident sicherlich alles mobilisieren
um möglichst viele seine Anhänger die
uns zu bekommen und möglichst viele
Stimmen zu bekommen also da muss man
noch gucken ob wir noch irgendwie einen
Kaninchen aus dem Hut Zauber der der vor
der Wahl sehr viele Wahl Geschenke
verteilt auch viel Geld verteilt da ist
nicht mehr viel da aber da kann noch
einiges kommen also der Wahlkampf der
hat der Wahlkampf der schmutzige
Wahlkampf kann weitergehen noch zwei
Wochen lang man weiß nicht was wird auch
wieder Anhängerschaft der beiden
Parteien reagieren wird also es bleibt
auch nach diesem Wahlabend nach diesem
langen Wahlamt spannend danke Markus
Rosch
es bleibt spannend die Prognose unseres
calls-ponenten in Ankara es wird
vermutlich schmutzig gekämpft in
Wahlkampf in den kommenden zwei Wochen
Professor Burak schupur war eine andere
Prognose unseres Korrespondenten wenn es
denn dann zur Stichwahl kommt im Moment
deutet viel darauf hin ist das eine
Ansicht eine Erwartungshaltung die sie
teilen würden dann wird es noch mal
richtig schmutzig zwei Wochen ja in der
Tat also die Opposition hat sich ja
keine Stichwahl gewünscht weil eben die
Ereignisse in Erde oder irgendwo
Bürgermeister Oberbürgermeister Ecke
immer müde so massiv angegriffen worden
ist unter dem sozusagen unter der
Beobachtung unter der Tolerierung der
türkischen Polizei ist das ein Prinzip
ein Vorbote für das was uns vielleicht
in den nächsten zwei Wochen auch
sozusagen reichen wird an schrecklichen
Bildern vielleicht auch einen
Ausschreitungen wir wissen es nicht
jedenfalls wird es nicht wird es nicht
stabiler
sondern eher instabiler weil alles
ungewiss ist und der Krimi jetzt noch
weitergehen wird gerade Präsident
erdogan hat es ja in den vergangenen
Jahren bei vergangenen Wahlen immer
wieder geschafft irgendein Ass aus dem
Ärmel noch zu ziehen ich will jetzt
überhaupt gar keine Unterstellungen an
dieser Stelle machen aber es passierten
irgendwelche Anschläge die er dann
ausgeschlachtet hat für den Wahlkampf
oder vergleichbare Vorkommnisse was
können wir da erwarten in der nächsten
Zeit ja das werden schwere Zeiten eben
für die Türkei sehr sozusagen unsichere
Zeiten auch die auf die Türkei jetzt
zukommen werden in den nächsten zwei
Wochen es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass
Präsident Erdogan hier eben auch
sozusagen noch ein noch eine
Überraschung Überraschung gut sein wird
und ähm und und vermutlich auch
versuchen wird natürlich die
Rechtsextremisten und das hinein Ohren
jetzt mit ins Boot zu holen und wie
gesagt das wäre wirklich nicht nur
Stillstand sondern ein großer
Rückschritt für die Türkei die Türkei
wird dann würde dann tatsächlich in eine
finstere Autokratie mit diesem Bündnis
unter den Rechtsextremisten gehen
abschließend kurz haben wir noch Zeit
welches ass hat
Ärmel ja Kemal Kühlschrank kann
natürlich auch Angebote machen
aber die Angebote sind ja begrenzt also
er wird auf der einen Seite unterstützt
von den Kurden die ja letztlich der
Königsmacher sein könnte sind in diesem
äh in dieser Wahl also die Kurden haben
ja aufgerufen die brokkolische Partei
Kämmer kirscht oder zu wählen und wenn
jetzt versucht Kämmer kirscht nur die
Rechtsextremisten mit ins Boot zu nehmen
bekommt er wieder automatisch auch
Probleme mit äh der poco dischen HDP
aber vermutlich auch mit anderen
Parteien also die Abspaltung der AKP
unter babajan alibabacan also die
leberpartei aber auch unter
professionfrage
eine ganz andere Auffassung haben als
eben der rechtsextremistin an Ohren die
Einschätzung von unserem Gast
Politikwissenschaftler Professor Burak
chopour mitten in einem Wahlabend denn
auch lange nicht entschieden ist und
unsere Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
sehen sie noch mal wieder um 23 Uhr oder
ab 23 Uhr oder bei meinem Kollegen mal
und ammoyale im Studio danke schön für
den Moment danke schön und wir
verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle aus
dem Bonner Studio und gehen nach Berlin
wo meine Kollegin Eva Lindenau mit der
Wahlrunde wartet bei ihr zu Gast die
Journalisten Dennis J von der Welt und
Stefan Andreas Castorf vom Tagesspiegel
herzlichen Dank für Ihr Interesse und
bis bald
[Musik]
die phönix-wahlrunde
die Wahllokale in der Türkei